dogs legion we'll see assassin's creed
valhalla
and some new announcements as ubisoft
shows off the latest and greatest just
for you
after that it's gonna be assassin's
creed valhalla we're taking an in-depth
look
in the post show so be sure to stick
around for it all
it's gonna be a fun day now if you see a
code on screen pop
up go ahead and enter that into uplay on
your pc
for a chance to win a free copy of
assassin's creed odyssey
far cry new dawn trials rising or the
division two
and without further ado it's time to
introduce the racers below we're getting
warmed up
belinda garcia welcome to the show hey
chris thanks for having me
excited to have you here a great time in
this warm-up mode
great time i mean i feel like you're
were you slightly sideways i mean that's
a good time
yeah it's a good time it's always a good
time uh fred carmichael i know that you
are known to throw a flip or two
uh how's it been going out here for you
uh now it's not going so good right now
but uh
yeah we're making it down very slowly
very well absolutely
i'm sure richard sanford will be happy
to hear the slowly part of that answer
richard what do you think
hey yeah oh no i'm super happy yeah you
all take as much time
as you need take it nice and slow
i would love that taking the scenic
route well you know
this this downhill route is definitely
trickier than it looks uh but
fortunately we're playing time attack
here this is the classic track mania
mode
for anyone who's familiar uh you just
get you know we're in the
in the on the track for about three
minutes and we and we get to run it as
many times as we can
trying to set the best time and trying
to top those leaderboards before
it is through oh it's dangerous though
it is hills are unforgiving i feel like
it won't be today
i feel like it reaches a point where you
just decide to like
throw the hammer down and like yeah at
this point control goes out the window
i'm just gonna try to careen down as
fast as i can
just kind of lift up your hands yeah
that's all i need i don't care
what way i love how three of us have
like 21 seconds right now
i know we're really close
hopefully i can get a little bit of a
smoother run
you know you know what they say slow is
smooth and smooth is fast
what do you say about going upside down
no big deal just got my fastest time no
big deal though what was it
uh 17 seconds what oh my gosh
[Music]
it may have been luck but uh yeah
it may have been locked yeah oh man now
now i'm feeling bad you didn't you
didn't talk to your car enough
nah you're right yeah you know what i i
should have meditated
yeah commune with the vehicle as you
were talking a big game about like
connecting on a spiritual level with
your
with your car you know what i heard that
from some like other drivers you know
it's best if you kind of really get to
learn more about your
car but that doesn't seem to be working
uh maybe 15 seconds 17 seconds oh you
improved your time a little bit rich
belinda you're nipping at my heels here
uh
this is this is good competition i like
this folks i like this
i don't tumbling down then driving down
[Laughter]
yeah it's like okay i can i can keep it
in control but then i'm going a little
too slow
and then i start going fast oh man
someone's definitely on on the
lid it's uh all over for me i
can't do anything i'm trying 20 seconds
to beat 17.
no oh i don't think i'm gonna beat it oh
man yeah this is down
do i have one last run
let's get a 12 second run here let's go
me and belinda literally upside down at
the same spot
i see you i'm restarting the checkpoints
so i don't know how you got 17 seconds
right
oh fred takes the time attack nicely
done nicely done
uh all right now we're gonna mix it up
and we're gonna check out some rounds
let's get into that now rounds is where
you
race the same track everyone starts at
the beginning at the same time and
finishes
you don't get to like loop it it's one
run and then you
get points based on your placement uh
and then after a few rounds i think
we've got
three per track here whoever's the point
winner
wins oh gosh no you were zooming dude
the trees are much more dangerous on
this map
there we go i like it i like it no
don't treat no okay cool don't tree
don't don't tree please but linda you
were zooming though
i was zooming but then the trees
happened
i tried to cut through the dirt and that
yeah that didn't end well to cut through
the dirt yeah i feel like trackmania
if you're going to take a shortcut you
better be airborne or something right
yeah
otherwise you're scrubbing speed off
badly
[Music]
complete control oh the wall man
i mean i'm consistently fast as long as
the track is just going in a straight
line
yeah which works for me dude it's not
really the track maniac
that band tool is all yours for it
see i i think i'm figuring out what
happened uh the previous round i talked
to my car
about uh going fast and not necessarily
managing the bumps uh now
you know the car's just like oh we want
to go fast now and i'm like yeah
yeah you gotta go fast uh rich is out to
a commanding leader yeah
he's got a lot of points up there i
don't understand
what's going on is that you are losing
no oh that's it
oh cut through it's like one
false move all right fred i see you ah
there we go i'm not too worried though
that's true i don't know if i can
actually catch up you got the points
right now okay yeah tim you got ten
points right
all right let's see what do we got rich
up top with the 26. oh fred in second
with the 19
then it's me and then belinda and shout
out to anthony who's in our spectator
seat
he's showing you the action and uh we're
gonna switch it up now and get onto
another match here
another rounds rich coming for you
now it's time to tangle with a little
bit uh of the
more i don't know challenging the right
word but uh
kind of mix it up elements of track
mania such as right from the start
we get this crazy blue yeah
don't fly over the edge oh you all
instead ran
right usually i fly over the edge so i'm
already
i'm already doing well give me a nice
start i'm i'm loving this star
it's so good oh fragrance why are you
zooming like this
so fast how how is everyone so fast i
don't know
too high on the wall okay recovered that
was a pretty slick actually bounce off
the wall i mean this is where it all
falls apart
turn right to go left or right
i don't like that at all it's like
unmanageable this huge ice wall you mean
a giant ice oh no no no no no no
no oh gotcha gotcha you just smoked me
at the head
it did
fred out to the early lead yeah i'm
gonna need you to hit one of those uh
pillars
all right i got you no problem no
problem happy tools
very considerate of you friend all right
you can tell
when i'm making not a great maneuver by
when my voice
[Laughter]
oh richard where are you going
killer chris the cursed pillar spoiler
yeah they think it's that thing where
like if you end up
you want to look at them so that you
know where they are and can avoid them
but if you look too long you end up
focusing on them
and then it draws you inexorably in
i i don't i don't appreciate that rich i
don't appreciate that all right
all right well as belinda and i battle
it out for third it's fred and
richard at the top oh no i didn't start
wink
[Laughter]
at the top battling for that top spot
here in our second round
competition obviously the stakes are
oh high i messed up yeah oh the pillow i
made it i made a made up mandomater
might be all over oh
oh my goodness i don't know what's
happening because you guys are behind
grass got me that time grass is also bad
all these terrains i just went so high
in here
no no no i do not have the jews to make
it across this terrain
uh melinda
i'll give this one the bridge i'll give
this one
i should have also gave the previous one
to me too yeah
you asked nicely so you know true true
yeah
got chris out of third
not a great round for me all right let's
go to our third and final map here
and settle who the real champion is
it's gonna be richard all right well
we're coming into the final
rounds match now the final track fred
you have been a contender for the number
one spot here but so far richard's been
getting the best of you what's your
approach to this track
he's he's fast but not fast enough i got
this one this one's kind of tricky so
i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty confident feeling good you're
feeling spry yeah
i'm good i'm good i like it melinda i
think you're out in front of me could
you please
like not is that it is that okay
we're all pretty close all correct we
are these
little bumps big bumps in this track
are very hard to maneuver over oh yeah
this this raised it's like it's banked
if you hit it from one direction but
then if you go over
the hump it's gonna be uh it's gonna be
a little trouble
oh just oh god just gotta believe keep
it keep it going
all right chris and belinda i'm gonna
need you both to beat fred please
oh you're going to recruit us yes you're
right
now we're out flying off the track right
at the beginning
the pressure i mean his gamertag is you
be rich is that a promise if we comply
yes it actually is you will be rich you
will be rich
be rich in satisfaction that richard won
i guess yes
i want to take let's take a number one
spot at least once during this
game broadcast i'm happy with three i
like the bronze
happy [ __ ]
he's out there yeah i don't know how
he's doing that
i told you you gotta talk to your
vehicle oh no no no
no no no no no no no no no
[Laughter]
that's a that's a bad one this one i
don't know this could be a close one
these points are adding up that was a
big bite rich down in third
all right here we go this is going to
settle it steady
slow and steady and take in the scenic
route
taking the scenic route take our take
our viewers on a lovely journey here oh
gosh oh little hippity-hop
just think about those hippity hops too
scared to go off the track i don't know
how you guys avoid it
fearless yeah that's that's pretty much
it
okay i mess up right there every single
time i'm getting quiet because i really
want to get a first place finish
on at least one of these races oh no
that's so bad thank you chris oh man
i can't believe i messed up again i did
it again
yes yes yes yes yeah i was never really
worried i wasn't
really worried i always knew helping me
sweating his palms are sweaty
[Laughter]
oh i don't like that prank in there you
be rich winsor match gg
gg
all right folks that's going to bring
our little uh let's play kind of
competitive segment here to an end
uh i want to thank you all for
participating uh belinda
nice work out there i tried i tried i
just
loved the scenery i was just taking my
time listen it's fun to get out there in
a fast car and just
do some things fred carmichael
close but no cigar this time around are
you plotting your revenge already
i'll get them next time richard is there
going to be a next time are you just
going off into the sunset with this w i
mean i'm definitely driving off into the
uh
the sunset but uh even if there is a
next time i don't think he's going to
beat me
and thus a rivalry is born or maybe
continued yeah
yeah continue thank you all for joining
so much
uh folks coming up next we're going to
be taking an in-depth look at the map
editor and some of the creation tools
in track mania but first let's do a
little schedule check in
after our track mania segment here it's
going to be the ubisoft forward pre-show
at 11 30 a.m pacific time where we'll be
seeing
some ai team mates coming to ghost recon
break point
getting an update from the crew 2 trials
rising will be showing off a fan
favorite
and we'll see a whole bunch more games
on display then
at noon pacific time when that timer
runs out it's going to be
ubisoft forward the main showcase watch
dogs legion assassins creed valhalla
some new announcements and
more don't want to miss that one and
after it's over stick around for an
in-depth look
at assassin's creed valhalla that's all
coming up here
shortly but now i've got augustine
davida producer at ubisoft nadeo the
creators of
trackmania joining me to talk about
creation
in trackmania uh augustine welcome
hello chris what's up here oh man
exciting times for you
your game has just launched people are
out there racing in droves how does it
feel
it feels great i mean it just feels
great the game is really really good
it's really an evolution of track mana
and
we couldn't wait for it and also folks
are out there
uh creating stuff we see right here
we're seeing some uh map creation sped
up we got a little time lapse thing
pre-prepared for us here as we talk
through
the map creation mode but i guess give
us like an overview starting off august
then
uh like what's your what was your team's
goal when like putting these creative
tools in the hands of players
uh so we always wanted the tools to be
easy to
to handle and um the big issue we were
facing that
there is too many blocks in the game
there is 1 600 blocks in the game
actually
and so we had to organize all the tools
and
to organize the new features and he's
doing a great job right now because he
knows what he's doing but
when you start making the first map you
really don't know what
where you're going to it's really hard
to get to
yeah when you say blocks sorry it's
interrupt but when you say blocks you
just mean all these little pieces that
we're seeing
of track yeah planted this way that way
this terrain that terrain
yeah that's how it works uh if we if we
um
every piece of the map is a what we call
a block so
it's it's some size and you can go like
diagonal
you have rods you have decoration
you have checkpoints start finish you
have boosters
and all of this makes a map so there is
so many blocks that there is an infinite
infinite combination possible in the
back editor
and there's also trees as i know from
personal experience
yeah you can get into them pretty
quickly in the game
so we're seeing here uh some they're not
this the players not just sort of
creating the map they're also like
okay i added a little bit now i'm
testing a little bit now i'm adding a
little bit
uh that testing is kind of like the
immediate feedback on
you know is this working is it not is
this the feel i like is it not
yeah you always have to to test what
you're doing just to see if
the curve is right if the speed is right
and we added some
some tools for that so for example when
you test and then you come back to the
game
you have your august to see what was
your speed at this time
and you know to try to reproduce or to
do better than him
so you can try uh every part of the game
and get really good in
really good map for the players
interesting
okay so when you're when you're starting
out you know obviously we're seeing
someone with
some map creation skills uh but when
players are starting out uh
you know is are there some some tools to
help them out are there
is it pretty you know are you what do
you recommend in terms of like okay
when you're starting out just try to
make like uh
a simple shape or you know try to just
put in a sick jump and that's
that's good yeah well in the free
version of trackmania there is
what we call a simple editor so there is
a simple editor in advanced editor
what we're seeing now is the advanced
editor so with all the tools
all the blocks and the simple visitor
editor is like a best off
uh of blocks so the blocks you need to
do like a
a simple track but a good one you can at
least make a good one
and i recommend to start with this and
then after you can get to the
to the advanced editor and make crazy
stuff like
like he's doing right now nice now is
that advanced editor pretty akin to what
the trackmania team uses to create the
actual
tracks in the game yeah it's exactly the
tools that we are
using every day to make the track we
every tool we put in the game we give
give it to the player as well
so they can make the same track as us
nice so you can challenge people to beat
you at your own game a little bit yeah
and sometimes they're better than us
they do track that amaze us i mean
i played some tracks that i always
remember
because it was so great well that's when
you hire them for the team right
yeah he happened it happened we we are
here a lot well
the guy doing the video right now he's
he used to be a player and he's still a
player and now he's working with us
and we always have like pro players
coming into the team
and designers and lover designers that's
very cool so
i mean we're talking here about the
track mania community then you know
they're people out there
going to be creating these tracks if
they're creating the tracks they want
people to race on them
how are they gonna how do they get folks
in the seats
you know to to race on their track it's
really simple with the with the next
track manual uh because now
once you're done with your track you can
just put it out there on what we call a
server review a map review server and
they can like everybody can come up and
test your tracks they can
rate your tracks and when they rate it
they give it for example five stars
afterwards if your track is good for the
players and we decide it's good
we're going to add it at what we call
track of the day which is like
the front page of the game and everyone
is going to play it
for sure every day there is a new track
made by the players
nice and so there's also but there is
also that like
server where and can any player just
kind of go in and be like let me see
what new creations people have today and
then rate them so if that's your
if that's your thing if you're looking
maybe for inspiration or just looking to
try some wacky new tracks that's
assumptions
that's why i do i always go to this
server like every day and try
new maps even if nobody is like pushing
them up right now there is always
maps pushed earlier in the earlier in
the day
so you can say it's always tracks to
test on new tracks to test
it's really great nice and so if you get
that
you get your track in there you get
enough uh get enough stars
get considered by the team and you
select them as a track of the day
then you know people are racing it and
there's some incentives for people to
get on that track as well right
yes every day there will be a what we
call a competition a daily competition
on this new track at 7 00 pm uh
cst and the
swiss competition rewards with what we
call trophies and those trophies
gives you uh like a rank in the global
rank in track manager so every day you
have to come
uh if you want to to come to compete on
this track and then you
you earn trophies and you get better in
the game and you can rock up in the
global ranking of the game
ah nice and speaking of competition we
are gonna be seeing some of the top
community racers
take on this very track here in just a
few moments folks uh in our next segment
uh right now we're talking with
augustine about uh
creation in trackmania and so far we've
focused on the the map editor the track
creator that we're seeing in kind of a
time lapse uh
fast forward here but there's also other
creative outlets i mean you can
customize for example the delivery on
your car
yeah you what we call skin you know in
trackmania
so you can create any skin you want with
what we call a skin painter
and you can share it really easily with
the world within clubs
in just one click you can find new new
skins that you like and you can
you can apply them or add them to your
favorites it's it's
really changing a changing game for
truck manager
it's never been it's so easy to change
ski and discover new skins
what's your what's your approach here
augustine do you like pick one you like
and stick with it for months or you like
switching it up every other day
mixing it up switching every day to a
new skin
i just go to the list and see oh this
one is nice so let's apply it and then
i have my skin in the game so every day
i can skin
excellent yeah it's so fun to see the
what people come up with and i imagine
this is also
something for you you know these are the
creation tools you use that your teams
use to create
the tracks the skins etc but uh you know
to a certain extent
you give the tools to the players
they're gonna come back and surprise you
yeah they're always like surprising us
with you
really great new new invention i mean
they can create mods as well gamebots so
they're going to create
new things every day and every day it's
it's blowing us
and uh one of the things that i have
really enjoyed you know
even when not playing track man is
seeing some of the like highlight reels
people put together because
as we'll see a little bit later on and
as you folks who know trackmania know
very well trackmania tracks can get
pretty wild
and the the kind of precision the the
this
the like just like excellent slick like
drift precision that people can display
looks really cool and you have some
in-game tools to help people showcase
that
stuff yeah on every track you can
you can save your replay and then you
can use it to make your own videos
so this tool is the tool is as well as
the tools that we're using to make
trailers
and at the same time players can make
their
trailers they can add up i don't know a
thousand cars on the same track to do
like a wave
what we call 1k project and it's really
good to see what they can do with that
because they can change the light they
can change the skins i can change the
color
so i can display text in the editor and
it's really really great well there we
have our completed track don't forget to
save your tracks when you're creating
them folks and we'll be taking a look at
this
there's an autosave excellent yeah i
understand you put a lot of people's
hearts
uh to uh at ease just then uh we'll be
taking a look at that track in action in
just a few moments here but augustine
before i let you go
uh we i wanted to touch base on just
kind of uh
again that community aspect of you know
how do people find these creations
what's a great way like
that there's the club system that sort
of allows people to connect to different
different clubs of friends or maybe this
club focuses on certain types of races
and
etc etc just give us an idea of how
people are going to
share these creations and discover
people's creations
yeah so in the game there is what we
call clubs and you can
create or join any clubs you want
private public
with friends for example or just a
streaming community within a club
and within those clubs you can share
skins you can share
maps you can create what we call a
campaign which is the same tool we're
using to create our own campaigns with
25 maps
and you can create also events so people
can gather around and
use the same skin for example or have a
club tag
and compete within each other on
leaderboards
and share everything they can they can
also share videos for example
it's really great well it sounds like
there's lots of tools for folks to
get creative to share those creations to
discover new stuff
in addition to just racing and trying to
beat the tires off of each other
yeah excellent augustan thank you so
much for joining us to talk
a little bit more about trackmania folks
remember trackmania is available now
download and play it for free on the
epic game store and on uplay
augustine thank you for joining us and
congrats
yeah thank you it's been great all right
folks we've got
some competitive play coming up here
just shortly but first another schedule
reminder
of the order of events today our track
mania showcase continues until about 11
30 pacific time then it's the ubisoft
forward pre-show
we'll be taking a look at ai teammates
in ghost recon breakpoint getting
updates for the crew too
hearing from trials rising about a
special new track for fans who like long
rides
and a bunch more then at noon pacific
time
it's the main event ubisoft forward with
watchdogs legion assassin's creed
valhalla
and more from ubisoft's upcoming lineup
of games
stick around immediately following the
show for a deeper look at assassin's
creed valhalla
and for now it's back to the track
joining me now is
omar ben abdullah live producer at
ubisoft modeo
to talk about all the ways that
trackmania can get
a little more competitive omar how's it
going man
very good and you how you're doing i'm
doing good i'm excited to see
some of the some skills i mean not that
yeah
not that we had no skills earlier this
is a whole different level right because
these are some of the top racers in the
community
yeah what we did basically is invite the
six or seven i think
best players of the closed alpha we
organized and
we'll be using them racing uh in rounds
mode so they all start at the same time
and the fastest guy win all right who's
your money on here at the uh
at the outset uh i'll just take the easy
peek and go with shawty since he won
that phone
there he is he's top of the top of the
pops right there yeah
and uh kenai viewers will note this is
the track we just saw
being created uh and actually the fifth
place player i think in that round is
the one who
made it so tona yeah you can step it up
i believe thank you
you probably can win that this one
around i believe it i believe it uh so
as we watch them compete i wanted to
talk to you a little bit more about
uh you know how people kind of like take
on new competitive challenges and drag
mania because
you know right from the get-go you start
playing there's the inherent competition
of racing you're trying to get a better
medal a faster time
uh and you're maybe you're racing
against your friends
but what are some of the other ways
people can kind of get into that broader
competitive scene basically what we try
to do is to design
features that will be good for any kind
of level
you are you have on track mana whether
you're a professional player or just
someone that wants to discover the game
and get better
each days um so you'll have a lot of new
ways to train
and get better at the game uh gaining
more medals uh maybe reaching the gold
medals on
all the maps of the official campaign
which is a great achievement already
uh you'll be able to play against vips
ghosts
which means that you'll be able to
compete against yourself or against
your favorite streamer against your
friends um
so yeah create a lot of possibility to
get better at check manager
nice so i i like the streamer touch
because then you know you're if you're
watching them in the chat saying like
you can kind of see
what when they've laid down the time and
then go take yourself to the track and
see how you stack up
but that's good like that's a feature we
love at the studio because you can
compare yourself against someone you
you would love to play against and and
maybe beat him and and
uh be happy with that excellent uh shout
out to tona who did take that second win
on the track yeah uh of his own creation
nicely done
uh so we're on to a new track here and
oh see that's the kind of move that yeah
what i'm flying out over the uh over
oblivion
yeah and so these folks have been have
played a little bit already but in terms
of what they're
seeing what competitive players are
seeing in trackmania what's kind of some
stuff that's going to be a little bit
oh my goodness no way that's scary
it's okay that's only the woman it's
okay
no wonder they're sending it no wonder
yeah uh
you know in terms of like uh okay so so
you've done your sort of like
you've done your solo competition you
want to like maybe compete with players
on a broader scale seek out
folks who race around the same time as
you like what's uh what's
what are some good ways to do that well
what
we have currently on the game will be
daily cups which is something completely
new for trackmania
where you'll be able to compete against
every player in the world which wants to
participate
every day at 7 7pm european time
and basically you'll be able to see how
good you are on the track of the day
and and compete against everyone in the
world and see how good you are against
each other
then obviously you have donations league
which will happen each week
where you'll be able to represent your
country and and see
how which country is the best basically
each week on the game
uh and then the open league uh which is
a great way to
feel the pressure of the professional
players because you'll play be playing
on the same
maps and the same format as the green
league so you'll be basically
leaving the the experience of a
professional player by playing the grand
league and maybe
if you get good maybe at some point
you'll be joining the grand league and
play against the 16 best players in the
world
oh my goodness well we see grand league
plastered all over this track here uh
yeah that's is that what that's the sort
of highest level of track mania esport
it is basically what we have on on the
ground league is the 16th best players
in the world you cannot have
anyone better than them and and we just
put them on the special format that we
designed
where everything is possible until the
end and the last second of the last
track
uh so it's really great to see and and
we're excited for the next season which
will start on on september
nice so in september more grand league
action coming your way
uh but you know there's a lot of spit
competitive space
in between the tippy tip top uh for you
to get involved and is that something
that you know
in terms of like i just booted up track
mania i've raced a little bit
is that going to be easy for players to
find what's the way to get into that
yeah you'll have in an in-game menu
which is called events
and basically you'll be able to check
out the events you'll have
you want to play maybe during the week
and and
it will be also easy for the people to
create events through the clubs
uh where you'll basically be able to
create an event in less than
two minutes and and decide which map you
want to have which kind of format
so we made everything easier for
everyone on trackmania
nice so that i mean that can even be
just you creating the events to just
play with your
friends or your also classmates or
whatever else yeah
nice uh and so that's so these clubs
this is kind of a way like
clubs are also a way that people can get
into you know finding people who
you know like to race at the same time
again or you know our friends are
connected through different ways uh and
the clubs can be kind of
of any size right yeah you can
be have a club which is completely
private and where you you play only with
your friends
or your your mates classmates or you can
just have a public
club which is available and joinable by
everyone
and and just have fun with a lot of
people uh doing a lot of events
and then organizing a lot of content and
maybe just a club that focuses on
huge jumps like the one we just saw
there like
yeah only gems maps and and the
the yeah that will be quite great i
would say
quite funny also this is a pretty close
match uh yeah
actually the top leader only has a few
points ahead uh
so i like it thanks for recruiting these
folks into into the action here
to to give us a look at some real some
real speedy real tight turns
yeah you can see how good they are by
their drifts and and
how well they know the maps obviously
since they've been playing the the also
for
i think a bit more than two two or three
months now so uh
they are getting used to the game and
yeah they're playing
really good compared to what we do i
wish i had watched them play before our
session earlier but
that's all right for the future um it'll
uh you can play against
a good ghost if you want to land them up
actually
that's true although you know can you
really learn from a ghost if it
just screams out ahead of you so fast
just try to follow it you work my way up
uh
yeah so these community events this kind
of uh
this this stuff that is organized
through clubs as like
so it's organized through clubs which is
kind of organic and players
all around the world can make that
happen but you at nadeo
are also sort of curating stuff and
experiences and events for players to
get into
yeah um what we try to do is to have a
mix of
community events well basically we have
players organizing events
that's something that is there for more
than 14 years now on trackmania so so we
love to see that
we love to see community creating
content on our game
we also organize ourselves our events
through the grand league the daily cups
donations league and things like that so
it's kind of a mix
of of trying to get
content for every kind of players and
also a way to
be able to create content and event
whether you're a great player or just
want to have fun with your friends
nice wow that's the time separating the
top yeah
that's really good and that's really
fast
is very very tight here as we move on to
i believe our fourth and final map of
this competitive section
and it's still really close all right
folks it's down to the wire
omar still believing in in your racer
shorty out there
i think he's first so i mean yeah
yeah and that's a great map everything
can happen there so
might be someone to over to or taking
shorty
do you like like that kind of map where
i mean it's exciting right because like
dramatic stuff can happen but also it's
a little scary like you can just
fly off the track and like ah well yeah
it's all gone you can go from first to
last
basically by by doing one mistake and
one short mistake
so um that's pretty exciting for the
spectators it's not that fun for the
players obviously
because you don't want to lose
everything on one turn but yeah that's
how you handle pressure on track mana
yeah you know at some point like fun
becomes like oh it's the thrill
you know you're risking a lot more for
the bigger payoff right
yeah uh what do you call this kind of
road surface here that's
it's like a hill in the middle i was
trying to figure this out earlier
actually we do have a name uh but i
don't like to use it i just let people
call it as they want uh
i'm calling it a different way in french
obviously
oh sure sure of course yeah basically
everyone can can
name the the the the world as they want
and and there's many ways to to to say
like
select the road we are seeing right now
the language of racing
uh yeah it takes many forms yeah
all right so we're watching the
competition play out here uh once people
you know trek mania is out now free to
download and play
uh what would you recommend in terms of
like okay i just want to get into
the into the competition against other
folks i want to challenge myself right
out of the gate what's the best way
to get that started to be quite honest
the best thing will be to play the daily
cap
because we'll be facing uh players from
all around the world on a track that is
known
only each day so the track of the day
map so you'll be able to see how good
you are against other people and and you
can do that every day so you can maybe
see your progression on the whole week
and maybe at the end of the week you'll
be able to be people that you wouldn't
even think too
about on on the early day of the week
i like that i like that that kind of
like because so you know a lot about
kind of uh
competition is that progression and you
know the sense of moving up in the
rankings but also of
oh like this person is always the one
who i see a few places ahead of me like
you're chasing them
you want to you want to track them down
uh now this is our last
this is our last race is that right yeah
last round and we shot each second so
i have some pressure to be quite honest
the pressure is on they're coming around
these
these like slot like
he's in there oh yep coming up around
this big
it's like s turn he's still first i
believe in him
he can feel he can feel the the positive
vibes coming from you
to watch and he's finishing first great
there he goes
like it looks like omar back to the
right racer
uh shorty coming in with a victory and
omar thank you so much
uh for talking about competitive track
mania uh anything else you want to
mention before we wrap it up
well obviously thank you for having me
and and thanks to the players for
playing uh
this competition thanks to all the
closed alpha players we had
because they helped us truly to make
this game better and and we're pretty
happy with what with
the track manager we have right now so
yeah just play trackmana it's free
and and have fun on it i'm pretty sure
you'll have and yeah that's it
all right omar thank you so much
trackmania folks it's out now on epic
game store
and you play go ahead and download it
get in there and get racing
now our time with trackmania is coming
to a close and it's on
to the next show ubisoft forward
pre-show is starting momentarily
we're going to take a look at ghost
recon breakpoint the crew 2 trials
rising new stuff coming from
all these games you're not going to want
to miss it and then when the countdown
timer hits zero it's ubisoft forward
the big showcase of the latest and
greatest upcoming games from ubisoft
followed by an in-depth book at
assassin's creed valhalla
we got a lot more in store for you so
let's go ahead and throw it over to kat
thank you chris and hello everyone and
welcome to the ubisoft ford pre-show the
main event will be starting in just 30
minutes and will feature news from our
unreleased games including
watch dogs legion assassins creed
valhalla hyperscape and more
now to warm up we have 30 minutes over
this from the games you're already
playing like ghost freaking breakpoint
trials rising and the crew 2 as well as
some exclusive behind the scenes so you
can get to know us a little better
so let's kickstart this ratio with an
update from justin's 2020
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
if you're a justin's fan and want to win
some cool swag head over to the just
dance website for all the details
for our next segment we have something a
little different than what we usually do
a few years ago ubisoft created the
ubisoft entrepreneurs lab and the open
innovation accelerator
this allowed us to create partnerships
and synergies with indie studios from
across the industry
and since so many industry events were
cancelled this year
we wanted to showcase several indie
projects and teams that ubisoft has been
collaborating with
over the past few years our first indie
showcase is developer machine and mensch
who is working on the curious expedition
2. let's hear more from the team beyond
the game
hi my name is masha and i'm a game
designer at machine match
machine bench is a small and diverse
indie game studio with eight wonderful
employees based here in berlin
our connection with ubisoft came through
a program dedicated
to create ever-growing relationships
with independent developers
to talk about and share expertise and
knowledge
we work together in mutual respect which
we much appreciated
we're working on the q's expedition 2
which is the sequel to our expedition
simulation game
this time the game was set in paris in
1899
during the world expo when the eiffel
tower was built but more importantly you
will be traveling to these mysterious
islands you will be interacting with
unknown tribes
fight dangerous beasts find many secrets
thanks to our procedure technology every
time you play it's a new world new
characters
and a new storyline that you shape with
each of your interactions
until it becomes really your own unique
adventure
[Music]
and we will have more indie guests
coming up later in the pre-show
so stick around now a while ago ubisoft
released its very first live action tv
show on apple tv plus
and it's a comedy about making video
games called mythic quest ravens banquet
and to keep the show authentic ubisoft's
red storm studio went above and beyond
by creating a playable sandbox for the
game
that is actually featured in the show so
now let's head behind the scenes for an
exclusive look
this is the home of clan okay it's very
clancy-esque
yes i get it all right now i'm starting
to understand right i too keep all my
awards at the
front of my office it's entirely empty
so mythic quest is uh ubisoft's first
live-action comedy
the whole show is about a team that is
developing a
super successful mmorpg and it's about
you know all the all the people within
the game development team
and their relationships and what they go
through in creating one of the world's
most successful games
all right incredible thank you but are
we sure
that we're finished when we heard about
what was going on we weren't really sure
if we were a great fit
because we always made shooters and
realistic
and we listened to the pitch and we were
super excited about the idea
so we thought all right what's what does
ubisoft have
that we could channel to fit this you're
[ __ ] me
yes you're [ __ ] me but i'm not
enjoying it it's for the game we started
on the project
i think we imagined we would just make
video clips that would run on screens in
the background or something
so it would feel like a real game studio
but once we saw the script once we
started collaborating
with the team we realized oh they want a
game like an actual game
of course making an actual game would
take years so we started
selecting the pieces that they really
needed for certain scenes and from there
it was not long before we said you know
what if we make this actually playable
what if we make it so you can connect a
controller
and control the characters and so that's
what we ended up doing
the thing that i love most
is this shuffle exploding people's heads
with this thing is
straight fire oh crunch man
we had requests to do things like make a
contagious
viral disease in which people bleed out
of their eyeballs first
then they bleed out of their anus and
they vomit and bleed out their anus at
the same time
we set it up in such a way that you
could
trigger it in stages because we didn't
know what the timing was going to be
the idea here is we can hit it and it
can control the timing of when things
are happening so
the next time you hit it he starts
puking out blood and at this point we
would probably have the camera start
panning back like
this and then you can hit the button
again and see the blood ocean itself has
started coming in
and so now they're all bleeding out of
the back end as well and then the
final is just everybody exploding in
bloody gore
and then this was keith's idea he wanted
the skulls coming up and bobbing up and
down in the water
david can we actually make this quick
i've got a lot of work to do stripping
blood ocean out of everything yeah
yeah releasing a disease in the game
right before a global pandemic was not a
great look today was the first time we
showed
mythiques ravens banquet to an audience
i've never seen it with more than
six or seven people in a room and so i
wanted to make sure
that we gave them an opportunity to
hopefully recognize
that this is a giant love letter to them
to the industry itself
i was a little nervous i got to be
honest i thought it was going to be a
little cringy but it was fantastic
i thought there was a lot of truth
and in the humor it's about time that we
had a show about our industry
you could tell when the audience was
laughing when they really hit something
that
that felt like the game industry i think
it's brilliant
all right so if you have not yet seen it
uh the first season of mythic quest
ravens banquet is available right now on
apple tv plus and a full version of this
making up will be coming out over the
next
few days all right now it is time to
fasten your seat belts and start your
engines
as we head out to leo france to visit
our team
at ubisoft ivory tower to get an update
on the crew 2.
hi everyone and welcome to the crew 2 at
ubisoft forward
my name is james reese i'm a community
developer here at ivory tower
and i'll be your host for this quick
glimpse into all the exciting things we
have going on
over the next few weeks it's been two
years already since launch
with six major updates and hundreds of
vehicles under our belt
and our latest update summer in
hollywood only went live a few days ago
let's have a look
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
we can't wait for you to get your hands
on what's coming there have been a few
speed bumps along the way
but over the past two years you the
community
have made the crew 2 a motorsports
playground where all players are welcome
and where anything is possible so thank
you
to the crew social exchange discord
reddit
and all of our players we've got a
little something for you in game to show
our appreciation
it's the 67 volkswagen beetle so let's
see what kind of hollywood twist you can
put on it
that's it from me there'll be more news
dropping over summer so
keep your eyes peeled starting with this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in case you missed it make sure to boot
up the game right now to unlock the
amazing
69 volkswagen beetle that was just shown
in the video
and stay tuned in the near future for
more info about year 3
of the crew 2. our next video is from
our second indie guest
bossa studios who will be injecting a
delirious dose of fun
with surgeon simulator too enjoy
[Music]
hi i'm nate from boston studios and i'm
a senior game designer on the upcoming
insurgent simulator 2. so at fossil
we're always keen to share game
development knowledge
and ubisoft has been a fantastic partner
in this they deliver lectures on
procedural content development
and player science and in turn we shared
with them the ideation processes that we
use to develop
initial ideas into living breathing
games which brings me onto surgeon
simulator 2.
we've really doubled down on the
physics-based pandemonium that the
series is notorious for
and we've pretty much expanded on every
other aspect of the game as well
so this time around you're no longer
just a floating and confined to the
operating table
you're actually a full first-person
surgeon with an entire medical facility
to explore
[Music]
and in addition to the levels that
you'll find in story mode
you'll now be able to create your own
unique levels and experiences
using bossa labs creation mode so it's a
really easy to use
intuitive set of tools that allows
players to create either on their own
or in online multiplayer with up to
three friends
everything players create can then be
uploaded and shared with the community
and here surgery really is just the tip
of the iceberg
during our closed alpha period we've
seen players create all sorts of amazing
stuff
from bowling alleys to space stations
pirate ships to
horror themed escape rooms and this is
before the game is even released
so we absolutely cannot wait to see what
players create when we launch the game
this coming august
and in fact if you pre-order surgeon
simulator 2
you can receive exclusive closed beta
access
[Music]
so for those of you who are just joining
us you are watching the pre-show and
ubisoft forward will start once the
countdown on your screen reaches zero
and make sure you log into you play to
unlock rewards as you watch the main
event
but now our next segment is about an
easter egg in the division two
so let's go behind the scenes with the
devs from ubisoft massive studio
in malmo sweden to find out more running
through collapsed buildings
climbing over fallen debris and
encountering makeshift living spaces
is common for players of the division
too within its post-pandemic environment
many players have spotted something a
bit more unusual
which has left them asking what's up
with all these rubber ducks
so there's a thing in programming
especially where you talk to a rubber
duck
and it's a way to solve your problems if
you talk to a robert duck and just say
things out loud
it helps one of our artists decided to
take this to another level and he used
the rubber duck
scaled up to like a ginormous scale and
put it in the level just to remind him
to
do something and it sat there for a
while and the rest of us kind of really
loved
this giant rubber duck sitting there for
so long we decided to put little
memorials
to it across the world
what started off as little memorials and
then we started adding stories to them
so there's one where these two ducks are
sitting on a bench having a date
together
and there's another one somewhere where
he's sitting with an umbrella hiding
from the rain
the idea of the ducks is similar to the
rest of our storytelling where we're
trying to add
some hope into the world because you're
coming in as a division agent to try and
save what you can and rebuild but you
need to know there's something there to
save
so having bits of happiness lets you
know like it's still worth
saving for these little happy moments
one shrine in particular
became a beloved fan favorite showing up
multiple times across
youtube and reddit so uh karen
how was your day well luke it's been
productive so the origin story of
productive
one of our level designers made an
amazing pun one day and we decided to
make a graffiti out of it and put it in
the game
and it became like a duck shrine and
players started finding it and wondering
where it came from
we've been finding these rubber duckies
all over the map it says here on the
wall
in graffiti productive and there's a
large
rubber ducky bigger than all the other
ones we've found
and he's uh he's he's got bottles of
booze all around him
not only that but he has a couple
soldier duckies
guarding a parrot in a cage but there's
there's more just like this
in the division two what's really great
about our community is they come
together they find
a common thing that they want to develop
or find or
get unlocked and they just put time and
effort into it
we don't put them in easy to find places
so that means players are genuinely
hopefully enjoying just exploring the
environment and finding all these little
easter eggs we've hidden around and also
not the easter eggs just the main part
of the game and all the storytelling we
put into it
i haven't found all of them i don't know
exactly how many there are
but they haven't found all of the ducks
yet encouraged by the community's
response to the ducks
developers recently hid another secret
in the game and made it the focal point
of an all-new community challenge we
actually put
tommy the teddy bear into the game who
told me the teddy bear is a trauma teddy
mentioned in a lot of lore but the bear
itself actually was not in the game
with episode 3 we put a bunch of them
into the world
actually opened up easter egg hunt for
him specifically
it's a nice little exciting moment when
you kind of open reddit and you see
someone's found the thing that you kind
of just
snuck in under the radar and no one
really knows about it
and it some of the players are really
clever there's
some hard easter eggs that some of the
level designers and gameplay designers
have put in
and people managed to solve it with no
help whatsoever
gamers are smart so now that you know be
on the lookout for both the ducks and
teddy bears
next time you boot up the division ii we
now have our final indie guest
thunder lotus games who were the 2017
winner of the indie series that took
place in montreal
so let's find out more about the
beautiful coziness of spirit fair in
this next video
hey everybody i'm rodrigo marketeer at
thunder lotus
we're a nindy studio based out of
montreal canada and makers of the games
joetten
sundered and our new game spirit fear
which is due out later this year
[Music]
for the past six years we've tried to
make triple a quality games with a
hand-drawn indie heart
hitting a quality standard consistently
in game dev is a huge challenge there's
so much
trial and error on the path and during
the sundered production we were lucky
enough to have the ubisoft entrepreneurs
program in our corner to help us reach
our goals
as co-winners of the ubisoft indie
series in 2017
we receive not only generous funding but
also crucial mentorship
and access to the ubisoft testing
facilities so we're grateful to ubisoft
for their support and helping us make
what we become our biggest success to
date we've taken that experience with us
onto
what is our most ambitious production
yet and that's spirit fair
which we're calling a cozy management
game about dying
in spirit fair you play stella the newly
appointed fairy master to the deceased
and estella you're going to build a boat
you're going to explore the world in
search of spirit passengers
seeking passage to the afterlife you're
going to spend relaxing
quality time with them you're going to
create lasting memories but ultimately
you're going to have to learn how to say
goodbye to your cherished friends
it's a game that's near and dear to our
hearts and something really special
we we can't wait to share it with the
world later this year so
look for it soon on pc on xbox one ps4
nintendo switch and xbox game pass
thanks a lot
and cheers
it is time for an update on our favorite
motorcycle platformer with the insanity
pain and triumph we all know and we
all love charles rising came out last
year but i think the team from our
redlink studio in helsinki has a little
surprise coming to the game
for the fans of the franchise so let's
take a look
[Music]
hi we're here today to introduce you to
an exciting new endurance challenge
coming to trials rising
but to make sure that we respect social
distancing guidelines auntie and i
decided
what fire the goose
[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to the gigatract
far from a remake of the classic track
from charles evolution
this is an all-new journey across the
world of trials rising in by far the
longest track that we've ever put in a
[Music]
trout
by far the longest track we've ever put
in a trials game
the gigatrack will take you across many
different environments
from the iconic
yeah i was just maybe you want to tell
them
the giga track is like life it starts
and it ends and it's long depends how
you enjoy it
and also one secret thing four there is
transfer to
one
[Music]
prepare for the ultimate test of trials
endurance gigatrack releases this
thursday july 16th for the low low price
of
50
you heard that right riders gigatrack
will be available for free to all trials
rising players when it releases this
thursday
you heard that right the giga track is
coming to the game and it will be the
longest most
insane track in trials history and it
will be free for all trials rising
players
now for our last game update the ghost
recon breakpoint team is ready to share
some details on their upcoming updates
ai teammates are coming to the game
let's have a look at the trailer
the time has come ai teammates are back
in ghost recon break point
and for all solo players they're gonna
be a game changer
available at any point after you have
reached erwan for the first time
fury fix-it and vasily can be activated
or dismissed at will
and from the beginning you will be able
to fully customize them
this customization includes all of the
physical attributes
as well as gear equipment or even full
costumes
your teammates can be tweaked just as
much as your main character
just like nomad your teammates will
adapt and react to the world of eroa and
its environments
and they will always follow your own
behavior
if you decide to go stealth they will
equip silencers and crouch
or go prone when possible but if you
decide to go loud
and open fire they will stick by your
side
when deployed you can issue different
orders to your teammates through the
order wheel
there are four different orders you can
give to your teammates
you can tell them to regroup on your
location to hold their current position
to go to a specific location and to open
fire on nearby enemies
these orders can be given at any time
even through your binoculars
and drone once they approach potential
threats the teammates will notify you
and mark them automatically
with a good look at your enemies you
will be able to set up a sync shot
where each of your teammates picks a
target you can even link it to your
three sync shot drones
for a simultaneous seven target takedown
the teammates have weapons equipped at
all times a versatile assault rifle to
accommodate all situations
and a primary weapon that you will be
able to fine-tune
indeed apart from mark upgrades and
passive bonuses
the full gunsmith is accessible to your
teammates
and their weapon of choice will have a
direct effect on the battleground
depending on the type of weapon they
have equipped the teammates will adapt
their engagement distance and rate of
fire
from close distance shotgun wielding all
the way to long-distance sniper shots
of course if you get taken down your
teammate's priority will be to try and
rescue you
to achieve that they will first focus
their fire on the surrounding enemies
before getting to you
and they will expect the same from you
especially as you will be able to carry
them to safety
if the situation requires it finally
the teammates will also be your best
allies in any vehicle
especially on the road and during
high-stakes pursuits
the teammates will be available for all
solo ghost recon break point players
on july 15th and we cannot wait to see
your reactions
we'll see you on the battlefield ghosts
hey ghosts i'm grace from the ghost
recon team as you've just seen the ai
teammates are finally landing in ghost
recon break point with our next major
update on july 15th alongside the ait
mates this update comes with a ton of
new content including a gunsmith upgrade
new pvp content quality of life updates
and more
you will be able to try it all during
our next free weekend from july 16th to
july 20th
but that's not all we've got one last
thing to show you enjoy
and we'll see you on aurora ghosts
[Music]
to anyone listening this is haruhi
speaking for the outcasts
we stand against sentinel's illegal
occupation of aurora
we call on all of aurora to join us
separated sentinel wins
but united we cannot be defeated
[Music]
[Applause]
so
and now our very final video for this
pre-show is another episode of our wow
moments comparing the craziest and
coolest clips from you
our players
[Music]
anyone else want to try to do better
than that
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i was going to interrogate him oh you
can target this guy though
oh okay
[Music]
[Music]
standing
[Music]
one
[Music]
so there's a line that people want me to
yell
but i can't usually do it because i'll
freak out my neighbours
but as you can see i'm at the crash in
ocean beach
and there's no one too close so
reloading
someone saw me i gotta go
[Music]
[Music]
if you also have amazing gameplay
segments you captured from our games
spread the joy and submit them on the
link displayed on your screen right now
all right guys it is time for us to wrap
up this pre-show don't forget to stay
tuned for our post show featuring a deep
dive into the world of assassin's creed
valhalla
thanks a lot for watching this pre-show
and enjoy ubisoft ford
see the games
join us
hi everyone i'm neil kumar and i'm very
excited to be co-hosting the first
ubisoft forward with the talented
youssef mcgee
today's show is all about getting up
close and in depth with all the exciting
games we have in production here at
ubisoft
i'm yusuf but there's no time to waste
so let's head straight to the streets of
futuristic london
and see what the hackers of dedsec are
getting into
the illegal paintings spreading
subversive and hostile messaging over
the last few weeks across london
are not the work of several people as
was originally believed
the criminals
[Applause]
[Applause]
authorities recommend not to approach
the individual
first they came for the foreigners and i
did not speak out
because i was not a foreigner
then they came for the protesters
and i did not speak out because i was
not a protester
then they came for the journalists and i
did not speak out
because i was not a journalist
and then they came for street artists
but i did not speak out
because i am not a street artist
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i realized that eventually they'd come
for me
and there would be no one left to speak
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get the hell
and there's nothing more
to the resistance there's a welcome
gift for our new members for the
disappearance of the criminal
you could have told me it was a bloody
costume partly
try it off the new key suspect has been
identified as david
ford a 43 year old london taxi driver
he has no criminal record but is
currently believed to be a terrorist
people have been asked not to approach
him the authorities advise all residents
i'm clint hawking ceo clinton has been a
longtime creative force here at ubisoft
and now he's bringing this vision
to watch dogs legion um so yeah what we
just saw was an amazing short film
by the director alberto mielgo that
uh was inspired by watchdogs legion and
looks at the game and the universe and
the characters through his
incredible uh artistic vision and visual
style
the city needs a resistance like the
film watchdog's legion tells the story
of
ordinary heroes setting aside their
differences in order to come together
as a collective and to fight for a
positive change
you can literally recruit and play
anyone who you see in the open world you
profile people that are interesting to
you you help them with their problem you
play their origin mission
just help me get some closure and i'll
do whatever you want sounds like a dead
sex problem
leave it to us and that's how you
recruit them into your team
and then they become the heroes of the
game and and the stars of your story
and what you doing in my flat you with
albion please
think more underground albion i'm
tickled
but think more underground what did sick
yeah right namchae govara you're done
and they make the story not only you
know unique to them but unique to you as
the player and personal to you because
they're
you know heroes that you've chosen and
invested in what would i say to fans i
guess i'd say you know
uh take care of yourselves stay safe
welcome to the resistance
our london town a modern metropolis
built on history and prosperity
only took 12 000 years to build it up
and
one night to tear it all down
oh my god listen up
get all your units to move in and lock
down the city
with london under attack by a mysterious
terrorist
the government turns to a private
military company called albion to keep
everyone safe what could possibly go
wrong
ladies and gentlemen mr nigel cass ceo
of
albion he's kindly stepped up to
establish order
[Music]
understand this i will not allow anyone
not even myself to jeopardize this
he will stop at nothing to permanently
control the city
london will be the first city in the
world to be made truly safe
nigel's not the only opportunist who's
taken a liking to this fair city
meet mary kelly head of the most
powerful crime syndicate in london
be sure and spread the word she and her
goons are using the dark web to sell
everything from party pills to people
this monaco is scary i know but i've got
to keep tracks on my merchandise tonight
you made me a slave you do not want to
ruffle her feathers
with the city out on its arse it now
falls on you
to build a resistance and take back
london
all right everyone faces on guns out
any of the brave londoners you see
walking the streets
can be recruited into your team
like him huh
or even her
everyone could become your next secret
weapon
in our first mission we need to get some
dirt on nigel
cass and that means breaking into albion
headquarters
inside the tower of london all the hardy
souls you see here
are people we have recruited from the
streets of london
they all have unique abilities and
you're free to tackle this mission
with whoever you like dick got my eyes
arthur can hack pretty much whatever but
as a construction worker
he has a particular set of tools that
make him handy
he can even call his own cargo drone
perfect for gate crashing when you're
not invited
and who needs a regular old gun when you
have a bloody nail gun
come here [ __ ] boy
[Music]
jesus christ what is that thing perhaps
we could approach this mission
differently
if you'd rather keep your distance we've
got you covered
amy is a drone expert
[Music]
what have we here a real tech
connoisseur
hate spiders but love this one
what an adorable creepy crawler
here we are let's class the place up a
drone expert
dolls have the unique ability to summon
their own drone
this little darling is fast and
she can also hack enemy drones turning
the tide in her favor
and if you are not into direct
confrontation there are more ways than
one to get the job done
recruiting an albion officer like
brielle here might be
challenging but it'll get you inside
restricted albion areas
don't mind me just doing v-con for a
bunch of insurgents
however do anything suspicious and
she'll probably wind up with a bullet in
the back of her head
you've been approved
we're missing the human element here i
can get the defense minister on the line
right now if you feel you must
[Music]
criminals running our streets illegals
threatening our families the police
commissioner himself
assassinated by terrorists well that
seems to be enough evidence
next up we're crushing mary kelly's
organ farming operation and
putting a stop to it that's good
the buyers expect high quality stuff
and we need a hard knot for this
impairing our frontal lobe again are we
bags don't disturb me in my natural
habitat
say hello to mickey the man lives for
his team
i put another air on the chest and
doesn't mind getting his hands dirty
[Music]
he does have a slight drinking problem
though
and he's passed out ah we'll
we'll come back to him you know what
let's go with someone a bit more
professional
it's almost crass to call him a hit man
some might even call him an artist
here's the fast and responsible
ah done and dusted not bad not bad if i
do say so in it
not everyone in london is a legendary
assassin or a super spy
but everyone can be a hero
so get out there find the best recruits
and build your resistance
[Applause]
it's time to take back london
plunging the player into a living
breathing city teeming with unique
locales and characters
has always been a central pillar of the
watchdog series
so what goes into building those worlds
here's amanda mutt to tell us more
my name's amanda munt i'm a level artist
on watch dogs legion
at ubisoft toronto being a level artist
i think is the coolest job
in video games because we do get the
freedom to
to kind of like pick and choose what
little details we want to depict and
we get ample opportunities to tell the
stories that we want to tell in the
spaces that we're assigned to
i have the capacity to hide things and
you know like small little easter eggs
in ac unity there was a boat somewhere
in the world that was covered in cats
and then it happened again in watch dogs
2 and
there may or may not be something in
london that is a boat filled with cats
in some capacity
so i was fortunate enough to go to e3
last year
some of the people that i was showing
our demo to were from london so
no matter where i dropped them in the
city they'd go oh my god this feels like
camden this
you know this feels like suther this
feels like westminster
when people are talking about some
detail that i've put into the world and
they're excited about it like that feels
so good as somebody who
you know builds these worlds with care i
love it
and now some news for brawlhalla fans in
just a few weeks
you'll be able to battle it out with
your favorite legends
on ios and android devices
three two one
[Music]
and now whether you need a tom clancy
action fix on the go
or want to dive back into one of the
most beloved fantasy franchises in
gaming
we've got you covered
[Music]
[Music]
the target is being held on the ground
floor
boom
okay
contact mode chain is down request air
support
target northeast rooftop roger inbound
danger close
i need an emp deployed now
[Music]
get back in yourself
[Applause]
hey take this
don't make me regret this
speaking of tom clancy it's been five
years since rainbow six siege first
launched and the community has never
been stronger
in celebration of this milestone ubisoft
montreal has put together a special
video to thank all the amazing players
and developers
that have helped siege become the game
it is today
[Music]
in december 2015 a small team released
rainbow six siege
a game built on a strong vision
creativity competitiveness
[Music]
that original vision was quickly adopted
by our passionate community
propelling it to a whole new level
oh my god i got it i got it
[Music]
this is such a special moment and being
at one year anniversary of rainbow six
now
game being stronger than ever more
players today than we had in the past
it means the world to us but we also had
our share of challenges
[Music]
um health that touches upon subject like
matchmaking connectivity
all those aspects are absolutely
critical to the experience of the player
through it all we're always driven by
you
our community and together we grow
stronger
[Music]
there is no sql plan and we're here for
the next 10 years so expect more rainbow
six in your life
for quite some time
[Music]
now 60 million players strong we're just
getting started
[Music]
from the devs that build the game to the
community that plays it
thank you
if you haven't tried it yet dive into
our new operation steel wave update
available now
and take ace and lucy out for a spin
a few days ago we introduced y'all to a
brand new multiplayer shooter
now it's time to venture into the
hyperscape
wait what was that a hack in the
hyperscape
that's not supposed to be there
let me get you all up to speed okay
about 30 years ago everything that we
feared about our future
started to come true we made some good
decisions
we might some bad decisions actually we
made a lot of bad decisions
so here we are 10 billion souls
living in the crush of the mega cities
but the people at prisma changed
everything
they gave everyone a way out
the hyperscape
in the hyperscape the biggest draw by
far is crown rush
this is where anyone can become someone
[Music]
if you get good at crown rush it can
change your life
[Applause]
but strange things have been happening
lately
rumors of people getting hurt
users disappearing from the real world
a darker secret lies at the heart of
hyperscape
and we have to find it
some of us are searching for a way up
some of us for a way out and for others
a new way all together that's what
brings us to the edge of the future
to the hyperscape
i'm jc creative director on hyperscape
jc's work on far cry primal and multiple
prince of persia titles has
established him as a top creative here
at ubisoft
for me what's exciting is uh we started
building it from scratch
seeing it grow adding ideas is really
cool
hello contender welcome to the
hyperscape
the game takes place in 2054. it's in
the future
where humanity has grown a little darker
one of the companies there they are
launching what's called the hyperscape
which is a virtual world and the
internet of the future it's the place
where everything converges
within the virtual world there is a
battle royale that takes place in the
virtual city of new arcadia
then we also introduce a lot of new
things you
get the opportunity to do parkour on the
rooftops to go into interiors where it's
much more narrow much more stressful
you get to go to the landmarks where
there's more opportunities to get
full items but also more players so it's
a risk reward kind of deal
we introduced the notion of hacks
special abilities that you can pick up
on the fly to adapt your tactics
with hacks you can do things like
teleport yourself you can wrap yourself
into a ball and
bounce around the battlefield so a lot
of abilities
that let you have fun that are toys that
you can play with
finally it's made as a spectacle so all
the viewers will be able to interact
with the game on different levels
through the twitch extension
so every few minutes there's going to be
a vote and viewers will be able to
decide what effect they want to affect
the whole battle so things like changing
the gravity
infinite ammo or stuff like that so
players while this happens really have
to adapt to all kinds of stuff that is
happening
so for me it's really exciting because
right now as we speak we are launching
the open beta and so
it's going to be available for free to
play for all pc players worldwide
i really want to thank all the players
all the streamers and all the viewers
who participated in tech tests and
who will participate in the open beta
here's a short glimpse
of what you can expect
[Music]
watch and learn how it's done
show time
that's mine
let's show them what i'm made of
go time
watch closely
here we go
cornerstone
[Music]
the digital world of the hyperscape gave
our artists and developers incredible
freedom when it came to designing
characters
production manager anna maria musca is
going to take us behind the scenes of
character design
[Music]
my name is anna maria musca i'm the
production manager for characters and
weapons on hyperescape
we have paid an exceptional amount of
detail to our characters
we switch different outfits different
fashion statements different tattoos
different
materials until we see them as real
individuals as real people
so the second you pick a character you
see them in game
you understand what their motivations
are and what drives them and what
challenges them
this was the first lineup of characters
this is our default base
but even starting from the hair down
everything has been meticulously thought
of
would this person actually like this
type of outfit would this person
enjoy the type of tattoos that we're
putting on them will they actually
like to be in this body
each season we plan to produce new
outfits for these characters
so we're hoping some of our players are
going to see the effort
and maybe even correlate some of the
accessories to what's going to happen in
the game
[Music]
we're very excited to see it in people's
hands
as we move into the next generation of
gaming ubisoft has been working closely
with console makers
to take advantage of all the
extraordinary capabilities
these new consoles will offer now we
have a special guest to tell us a little
more
hey everyone phil spencer from xbox
with watchdog's legion ubisoft is
supporting smart delivery
so you will get the absolute best
version of the game
on any version of xbox you're playing on
on series x
you'll get to take advantage of the
amazing work the team has done with
directx ray tracing
to create an absolutely immersive
version of london
like you've never seen before ubisoft
has a unique ability to create
immersive worlds setting a new bar that
continues to drive
our industry forward i'm a huge fan
of assassin's creed i love the time i've
spent
exploring the world in assassin's creed
odyssey
and i can't wait for you to see the game
play
from assassin's creed valhalla that's
coming up now
all right we know you've been waiting to
hear more about this game since it was
announced back in april
and now it's time for a deep dive into
the world of vikings
my name is julian and i'm the producer
of assassin's creed valhalla
so a couple of weeks ago we announced
assassin's creed valhalla and the
reaction from the fans was just
amazing the time period of vikings is
really really inspiring when we did our
research
we found that you know there were not
mindless barbarians
vikings were actually farmers trying to
find new lands for them to settle
and so they had really human motivations
so for us to have this opportunity to
tell kind of the real story about
vikings
and kind of separate ourselves from the
myths and the folklore
is really something that drove us to
make this game
the team went to norway and england to
take the same roads that the vikings did
to really experience what it meant to be
a viking at that time
[Applause]
and then leaving norway which is
barren but majestic and just coming
by boat in england and see those rolling
green hills
full of sheep full of life is just this
moment that most likely the vikings
felt as well you need to see this land
of opportunity
and this is exactly the feeling we want
players to experience in this game
[Music]
it is a personal adventure you know it
is the story of avor
a viking chieftain avor
is either a male or a female you decide
when you start the game
they will have to leave norway to settle
in england because
you just can't live in norway anymore
there's too much political pressure
no resources available
obviously in england it's full of
anglo-saxons and other people
and they don't really want you there so
you will have to fight your way there to
kind of
build your own settlement and see your
clan prosper
vikings were brutal warriors
and the fact that they were mastering a
lot of weapons coming from
the medieval times really inspired us to
kind of revamp the fight system
to leverage the brutality and the
intensity of viking combat
vikings were not only fighting
face-to-face
they were masters of stealth and
deception when needed
they use basically any sort of tactics
they could use
to win the battle so we want to portray
the full range
of combat that you can imagine coming
from the vikings
we are very happy to finally be able to
show you the game we're all been working
on
so please enjoy deep dive
into assassin's creed valhalla
assassin's creed valhalla you will
relive the epic saga
of the viking invasion of england
you play as avor a viking from norway
who will lead his or her battle-hardened
warriors across the north sea
to the british isles avor is driven by
an ambitious goal
to build a thriving norse settlement in
a hostile land
for the good of our plan it is time we
go our viking
today we raid the tomorrow we may build
england is a dark age tangle of broken
kingdoms and warring dynasties
a land of opportunity and riches
as you prowl england's rivers by
longship you may raid locations you spot
from the shoreline
ground your ship and blow your horn to
lead your raiding crew into battle
[Music]
your crew will assist you in all your
raids
fighting enemies battering down doors
and stealing cargo too heavy for one set
of arms
whatever riches and resources you
pillage may be used to develop your
settlement
giving you access to useful services
better tools
and new settlers at the heart of your
settlement is the alliance map
it will serve as a record of the allies
you have made and a guide for future
opportunities
the viking age was a time of warriors
and legends
in valhalla you will find the largest
variety of enemies
ever assembled in an assassin's creed
game
every archetype offers a unique
challenge
some will coordinate with their allies
for special attacks
while others will use nearby objects to
their advantage
including the bodies of fallen warriors
to face these attacks you must find and
exploit your opponent's weaknesses
to gain the upper hand take the fight to
your foes
with a host of brutal new combat
abilities
snare them with a viking harpoon pummel
them with throwing axes
incapacitate them with the new stun
system to keep them at a distance
or finish them off
dual wield any two weapons you wish to
unleash a deadly combination of attacks
customize your fighting style as you see
fit
and become a legendary viking warrior
together
all combinations of weapons are
available to dual wield
including two shields
not all situations call for violence
in this new land a viking must find a
way to adapt
as a war is not welcome in england you
may need to outsmart your enemies
avoiding unwanted attention in towns and
bustling cities
use avor's hood and cloak to blend with
crowds and slip past watchful eyes
an unseen hunter among the people
from capital cities and villages to the
dense forests and rolling hills of
england
exploration is vital to keeping yourself
sharp
you must feed off the land if you hope
to endure
hunt and forage to replenish your health
and fortify your equipment
search pagan temples and roman ruins for
new activities and challenges
to strengthen yourself and your
settlement
the more you explore the more of
england's secrets you will reveal
[Music]
romance show
but as you push deeper into england the
enemy
will push back in a series of climactic
moments
assassin's creed valhalla will feature
massive assaults
in which you lead a war's army into
battle against heavily guarded saxon
fortresses today we will reclaim her
today we fight for your land and
tomorrow
we rebuild foreign
assassins creed valhalla will transport
you to wondrous
and haunted lands inspired by norse
myths
and england's pagan roots it will
challenge
and surprise with unforgettable
characters
thrilling triumphs and tragic losses
giving you the chance to live your own
viking saga
9th century england is truly unlike
anything the franchise has seen before
assassin's creed valhalla were released
this holiday season
on xbox series x playstation 5 xbox one
ps4 pc and stadia
we're close to wrapping up today but
before we go our ceo
eve guimo is here to share a few words
i hope you will have enjoyed what you
have seen today
and that you will love playing these
games i am proud of our teams for
delivering
an ambitious broad and creative lineup
of games
and we haven't shown you everything yet
in fact
we have a lot more to come so you will
have
another ubisoft forward to reveal even
more
about our upcoming games but before
ending this show we have one more thing
to share with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
it's beautiful amigo
perfect but useless
i have something for you diego give me
your hands
papa now the grenade is simple
it has four basic parts the shell
which contains the explosive the fuse
the handle and of course the pin
what are you doing breathe
breathe the pin
simply holds the handle in place
it is only when you let go that this
grenade goes
boom
follow me
now
i am president which means that someday
you will be el presidente
and our people they do not know how to
be happy
they are torn apart by opinions noise
indecision strangled by their own
freedoms and even if you have love in
your heart
even if you want what's best for them if
you only want to save them from
themselves
they will hate you everything you say
do believe will be wrong
[Music]
they will answer your screams
call you evil
a monster
and give you this
so you tell me are you evil
are you a monster
because our country is like this grenade
except it has two basic parts
our people
and you and you must clutch
them nice and tide or
we all go boom
do you understand now
[Music]
brewed
and with that we're wrapping up our
first ubisoft forward
today we've seen the next generation of
assassin's creed
the birth of a resistance in watchdogs
legion
the cyber chaos of hyperscape and the
epic reveal of far cry's newest
installment
along with so much more remember we'll
be back
later this year with another ubisoft
forward filled with tons of game news
and updates
thanks for joining us
hey everyone welcome to the ubisoft
forward post show my name is yusuf
mageed and this
is assassin's creed valhalla we're gonna
take a deep dive into about 30 minutes
of gameplay and we're joined by a very
special guest here
hey everyone uh this is philipp balzaram
otherwise known as fizz
i am the quest director on assassin's
creed valhalla
so fizz we're setting up here for what
looks like an epic encounter
tell us exactly what's going on here
yeah so here we're
midway through the uh the quest that
we're showing um for you before
here we're looking at the assault of
bird castle
um so these are big moments that usually
uh
sort of culminate at the end of the
story and so here avar
or viking raider is taking a group of
raiders and ferds into bird castle to go
and take down ruid and his clan
so who exactly is ruid and why does avor
sort of want to pick a fight with him
basically rued comes into play about
halfway through this story arc where
at the beginning of the arc that this is
something that that happens before
red basically caused a lot of turmoil
within the territory and
oswald who's the sort of elder men to be
to inherit this territory
needs your help to take him down oswald
having just been
defeated in a previous quest and so here
this is revenge but also accomplishing
your ultimate goal
so fiz as you're talking we're seeing
some of the combat of
valhalla can you tell us a little bit
about the changes to combat this time
around
we wanted to uh basically add a lot of
new mechanics to it so we added like
some dual wielding for the player
like a stun system in there and we
really needed to do this to sort of
portray that sort of the brutality that
comes with being a viking in the same
age so it sort of fits into that
the time and the character
is that you shut your arse tweak spine
here avor has taken her entire army
through the assault and finally
it's revealed that our our elder man our
ally
oswald is still alive and ruid has him
captive this is what it comes to wolf
kissed
two danes fighting over a filthy saxon
[ __ ] son
if this swine is your prize come and get
him
[Music]
so now that we've seen that oswald is
alive we have ruid within our sights
what's the next step here so the next
move for avor is to
finally uh face off against ruid she has
her allies they can take care of the
rest of the army
now it's time to go one-on-one against
ruid
in one of our boss battles actually your
battle is not just one
and it's worth pointing out actually
that here what we're showing is the
player um
going and facing off against ruid
aggressively but you we
tend to always have a to support a 360
degree approach in these things
so player could have approached us a
little bit more stealthy and gotten
at least like a good critical hit on
either ruid or his wolf and so you can
play this a little bit more
strategically
if that's your playstyle so we're not
only fighting ruid here but also
his pet wolf right you're one of my
preferred strategies is to eliminate the
wolf first
just focus fire on him it takes at least
one opponent out of the
combat now rude will have extra
abilities that come into play if you do
eliminate his wolf
um but i think having one opponent less
in the battlefield
makes for a good strategy uh in the hole
for all your efforts only the cold dark
of nephilim awaits you
valhalla is my destiny that thing will
not be met today
why don't they should be roomed
wolf-kissed
made froze not treated as equals we are
better than this
than all of them do not drag me down to
the sewage
wallowing tooth and nail for a section
you throw in with these wastrels these
are swine evil no
he should be tried before god a lawful
assembly
all right so we've defeated ruid we
freed oswald
what comes next oswald in this case
prefers
for rude to be kept alive and so you
basically have to choose are you going
to go against his witches
or to stay true to your nature so we
have this choice to make
but before we get into that i want to
rewind a little bit because
we just did this big grand assault but
avor couldn't have done it alone
uh she clearly had to recruit some folks
along the way
get some troops get some allies so let's
actually rewind and
see how we went about first gathering
those troops
right so when coming up to an assault
it's a game of numbers
avor can go into pretty much any
location and
be a stealthy viking eliminating some of
the
assets which ultimately would be a
strategy you can do that
and you'll have some um some of the
ingredients or
of the assets there that will have been
sabotaged but you still need
a army so here what we're seeing is avor
going around the countryside
and raising what we call a ferd which is
the men and the women of the territory
who come up and fight in the name of a
king so here
avor is going around and trying to
convince people to fight in the name of
oswald to finally take down the
oppressor that is ruined
defending east anglia defending you will
you not do the same
what do you in defense of the last cars
yeah so she's really using like the
image and like the
the leadership that ellswolf had what he
meant to the people in his name she's
going to recruit these people
pretty words dying but the men of
thailand have their own battles to fight
so we're told by this reeve that there
are troops there are allies that he
could add to our cause
but first we sort of need to do him a
favor is that right yeah so
um obviously these people have been run
down by ruid
and the impact he's had on the territory
so i think a lot of these people have
sort of
lost hope and so you need to show them
that there is hope
and so here avoir is basically helping
them take back one of their
their prized locations um by taking a
couple men
and raiding a nearby um
township basically taking it back for
the people and showing that there's
there's
a reason to continue fighting and then
get them on your side
[Music]
when a4 does this obviously you have
access to a full suite of abilities so
again the improvements that we've done
to the fight system um
you have some brutal axe throwing in
there you have archery or like a range
combat abilities in there as well
so really again like depending on what
your play style is you can customize
your loadout
and go in there how you wish
fizz we just saw this giant pulse go out
what exactly was that
so that is actually this is what we call
the odin site the own side is basically
our interpretation of the uh
the eagle vision from previous games and
we thought it was good to
sort of bring that back it's basically a
voice intuition it's how she perceives
the world
when blair uses that you can it'll
highlight basically interactive objects
like things that will bring her an
advantage so
we'll have arrows like health
consumables that are in there
so it really is like a good way of sort
of understanding the world and showing
you
like things that you can go and touch
yeah i mean speaking of things we can
touch we just picked up this awesome new
weapon
it's something we wanted to play with on
assassin's creed valhalla
where we have fewer weapons in the game
but you can invest in them more so they
become your
weapon and so depending what your
preferred
play style is or your preferred weapon
type then you can go and choose i'm
gonna
i'm gonna fight with this weapon and
invest heavily into that
not only are we looting weapons but we
see something here called the book of
knowledge can you tell us a little bit
more about that
they unlock skills for the players so
here you can see the valkyrie dive that
has just been unlocked
we have these spread out throughout the
world so again to promote
exploration and discovery as you travel
through the world and you explore
locations you can find these books that
will add abilities that you can go
and invest in put into your loadout then
go into the
different locations with the different
quests in the game and use though
depending on what your play style is
now we've recaptured this village we've
secured more troops for our assault
let's jump back now and figure out what
we want to do with ruid
[Music]
the rightful king of east anglia has
spared your life today
and so it will be
[Applause]
compassion is a virtue suited for anyone
evil
including you thank you
avor decide to let him live rude is
really angry about that
being a norse viking being put to the
death in battle is your
road to valhalla so he was basically
denied access to valhalla in this
situation
obviously all of these decisions come
into play later on in the game so
we have very difficult decisions for the
player to make we didn't want to have
easy decisions yeah you know when i was
playing i i decided to listen to oswald
and spare ruid's life
but what exactly is the relationship
like between avor and oswald
so the relationship between avor and
oswald is is is an alliance it's uh
basically
avor is surrounded by territories um
that
initially getting into england are
hostile towards her and
um obviously if you want to set up a new
settlement you want to have
make sure that your neighbor is friendly
so here in estanglia
oswald is the man for the job where
putting him
into a position of power would help her
sort of secure her territory
um so earlier on to the territory
avor comes in here meets oswald the
problems he had with through it are sort
of put to light and
going through the arc you basically help
him deal with rued
and and aligning basically danes with
saxons
in one uh territory
[Music]
so fizz we've completed the assault
we've gotten our hands dirty with some
combat
taken down ruid we have this big open
region of east anglia so before we head
off to oswald's wedding what do you say
we head out have some fun and see what
we can get into in the open world
that sounds great so we see a
cat here with a speech bubble above it
and you best believe if you let me talk
to a cat i'm gonna talk to a cat
yeah these these are some of our um
some of my favorite moments actually in
the game where we put in put out a whole
bunch of events throughout the territory
um and it sort of rewards again
exploration going around
it's a it's a chance for us also to sort
of showcase a different side of avor
a lot of the quests sort of deal worth
more with like politics and warfare
and this shows a slightly more human
nature to her uh so it permit us to
explore that character a little bit more
and so here basically like you're trying
to help a kid
with his cat and ultimately get that cat
to sort of
join your crew as a cat raider
you just said cat raider way too
casually you're telling me i could have
a
cat viking raider on my long ship that's
that's exactly what i'm telling you
oh my god yes i love it perfect
so yeah as you're riding around the the
the rivers of england you would see a
cat
basically walking around your longship
keeping your viking raiders company
you know speaking of the viking longship
we're seeing some of that gameplay here
now
can you talk a little bit about how that
works and functions in valhalla
yeah so so starting out on this project
um
i think the viking long chip is one of
the the biggest images that we all have
when we think about vikings
in our game and so vikings had this this
awesome
design for lawnship that had a very
shallow haul so it permitted them to go
very far inland
very quickly and you could basically
disembark uh
viking raiders like on pretty much any
shore
we added that into the game where you
can basically sail up to
any location and then just decide to
disembark with your guys
and raid a location loot all this
treasure get back in the ship
and then continue really uh sailing down
the river
um to your next opportunity
so i know past assassin's creed games
allowed for songs and things like that
to be
sung on ships will valhalla have a
similar version of that
yeah so this is something we actually
wanted the crew of your ship to become
like
your your home away from home so we
added
stories and songs into the ship
so basically as the player is going
around you could decide to
have your skull sort of sing a song for
you as you row down the river
but you can also decide depending on who
the raiders are in your ship
to hear more about their life so you can
actually queue up stories
and they'll give you a little bit more
background who they are so you get to
know your
your sort of fighters as you're
traveling around the world which is a
cool
moment so here we're seeing a bit of a
different view what exactly are we
looking at
we had this on previous assassins where
you would like ride on
on your horse and you could pull out
have the road the horse sort of follow
the track
we have a similar thing for the ship
where you can put up your sails
it's cruise control for the ship so you
can pull back take in the scenery
listen to some songs or some stories and
just take it all in
so you know speaking of viking songs we
have an activity here that's not exactly
singing but kind of related right yeah
so here what we have is what we call
flighting which was an activity that
norse people partake in
they would like to have a battle of wits
and and
sort of poetry where insults would be
thrown back and forth between each other
the idea was to try and have a good
insult
but also to have a good rhythm and
a good rhyme in there so it's basically
a precursor to
rap battles
here's the silver now begin
to all those whom i speak they say ava
was a clod
then you're speaking to fools and their
knowledge is flawed
wow how exactly did you go about being
successful in one of these
the trick behind a good flight was to
choose the right
insult um identifying the right cadence
and then trying to find what rhymed the
best i'm known for my might
interesting interesting
silent whispers all claim that you're
terribly dense
then you've clearly misheard them my wit
is immense
oh you lucked out with that one
well what a surprise evil of the raven
clan is a true talent
i'm shocked don't believe everything you
hear unless it touches on my flighting
then heed every word take the coin so
now that we've
proven our sharp tongue and wit uh i
think it's time for a bit more relaxing
activity so we're fishing here
yeah that's it um so we gave avor a
fishing line so you can actually throw
out a line and
and go catch some fish um this is used
basically to
uh uh to play into our new health loop
where
the player will lose health in in the
world and it doesn't automatically
generate regenerate like we would have
in the past so you actually have to go
out and
get some some supplies so you'll find
mushrooms
uh and some food that you can gather but
here like we you you can
also catch some fish and consume that to
regain some health if we also
will sometimes have it in in certain
quests so it's a good way to sort of
chill out
on the side of the of the water and just
again take it all in
so this is what we call one of our
offering alters
so the idea is that you you find these
around the world
and you make offerings with it and so
it'll take like animal parts and stuff
that you can find throughout the world
here what you're seeing though is sort
of like a fancy version of it where
as you do your offering you get
interrupted by some some kids that
basically come and
steal your stuff so it's just a way for
us to sort of showcase that like
the systems and activities of the world
can sort of play in with some
some quests and some little events so
it's our way to sort of dress up these
moments and
make it all fit inside the the whole
experience yeah this seemed like a
really sort of unexpected turn for
what i thought was going to be kind of a
simple interaction
yeah and it's really what we were trying
to do with these events is to give
another dimension a war
other than just you know the pure rar
viking or the politician
because you can imagine at some point
that will grow old if you're always
telling
that that that version of the character
so it lets us really go into
the depth of who is avar uh what
motivates her
how she can interact with the world
outside of uh
warfare and politics stealth needs work
ah we were close and it also showcases
like a different
facet of the world at the same time it's
not only a war so
it just widens the breadth of the
stories that we can tell
so who exactly are these two children
these are kids of
east anglia they are going through tough
times
um with whatever route it's been doing
to the territory
and so they're just here trying to
survive and and
basically exploit the people that are
there to make offerings
it was kind of nice to see that award
wasn't really necessarily upset at them
for stealing
and you know after you talk to them you
have the choice of helping them you can
you know give them food
give them some money um or you know
maybe just say hey good luck
on your way yeah and then this is
something we also wanted to do a lot
like
so here we're doing an event we do it in
quest as well but we want to do
you know give a lot of this agency into
players hands so that
they can sort of shape avoir a little
bit
um uh who she is so it represents them a
little bit more and they can role play
that a little bit uh better
and again it just gives her like a
little bit more humanity in these
in these moments provide for small
walkers
here large walker a necklace yes
it's a saint martin seal you're welcome
here anytime
large walker you're one of us now visit
us okay
i will take care now small green walkers
so i think ac veterans might recognize
this here
but uh what exactly is a war chasing
down
yeah so here you're seeing avoir um
running down one of our tattoo
images so this is challenging the player
on free run abilities but also for
fans of the series sort of pulling at
their heartstrings for
some beloved features so are we gonna be
able to tattoo avor
yes by collecting these tattoos you
actually bring them back to your
settlement
and then you can customize different
body parts having different tattoos
everywhere
so again another form of expression and
sort of to represent that
that viking culture
is one of my favorite things when i was
just out there exploring east anglia was
coming upon a house or a building
and realizing that there was a chest
inside but that there was no easy way in
and in this case i saw all the doors
were barred but i knew
that because there was a chest in there
there must have been some way to get
inside
so i went around the back and you know
found a way in yeah i'm glad you
actually caught on to that you're
pointing at something that we wanted to
work on a lot on valhalla where we
wanted the exploration to make you feel
smarter so we played a lot with puzzle
solving so
making sure that every house that you
find sort of
appeals to you like it draws your
attention and then when you want to come
and explore
it's not it's not given to you you still
have to work for a little bit so
it'll challenge you on your observation
skills um
logic just trying to find how do i get
into this so we play a lot with
uh level design quest design to offer
challenges to players and
you basically come out of it like with a
better feeling for the exploration but
you also get to see
more of a story behind these locations
which we've crafted so
it gave us a little bit more time to
sort of slow down the experience and
and tell a different version of a story
a poor victim of someone's fury
yeah i mean speaking about exploration
and just finding things out in the world
i was just wandering and came across
this clearing and found this kind of
morbid altar yeah so this is this is one
of our bigger events that we
we have scattered in the world so as
avor explores
um she can find altars like this
and by interacting with them here it's a
trap that's been set
um for by by this character named regan
now there's a bigger story behind all
this there's multiple
steps to it later on um so this this is
one of the moments
uh it it permits us to go into a
slightly more
mystical realm and play with a boss
fight that has
more magical abilities if we will
and and basically have this awesome boss
fight in the middle of the swamps
and so here the abilities that you see
reagan using like
are a little bit on the mystical side of
things what's happening is avor at the
beginning in that trap is poison
and so she starts sort of hallucinating
seeing the world and sort of different
uh light and filter um and so that
that's sort of what lets us
go into this this the the realm of the
weird
spirit of my father's rage fill me
so we just saw here that regan belongs
to something called the daughters of
lyrium
yeah that's correct by finding the other
daughters you'll get a little bit more
backstory on who they are so we don't
want to spoil that too much
but it creates like a sort of greater
story that is not
on the main path in any way but it is
still very rich and adds to
the lore of this world and actually
plays into history
so we just had a really exciting really
intense boss battle
i think it's time for something a little
bit more relaxing and calming now
yeah it's all here it's all about pacing
yourself with the highs and the lows so
here we have
a low chill moment of what we call
building a cairn
so avoir as she explores the world will
find these sort of meditative areas
where
you have a pile of rocks that you could
just stack on one and
on top of another using physics and i
mean yeah
the ultimate goal is to try and get the
highest pile of rocks
but really it's about taking in the
sights
relaxing taking a step back and and
built just building something
together we stack stones into cairns
these yes think of this as a test of
mind
and weight stack the cairn stones high
and wide into any shape you like
i mean you can spend as much time as you
want building these things making as
high as you want as weird as you want
i'm sure like a lot of these stuff will
end up on the internet like people
comparing
structures and the cool thing is that
once you've built it
and you decide to get out of it it sort
of stays there and so that's yours right
and until the moment where
you come back and you want to build a
new one it's sort of cool that we were
able to
to give that to players to express
themselves
at this point in the demo we've explored
east anglia
we've met some children we've broken
into a house we fought a boss we built a
cairn
i think now it's finally time to go and
head off to oswald's wedding
yeah so this is this is the moment it's
all been building up to
um by the moment you get into the
turries territory sort of like mentioned
by oswald that
he's trying to uh get married with his
dane lady and so as you go through the
arc
um that's sort of like the underlying
thread really it's about
ruid creating turmoil in the territory
and helping oswald sort of
get above that and and show that he's a
good leader
and so you finally after going through
all of that arc
uh finally get these two together go
through their their wet at their wedding
and you're invited to attend the
ceremony
um and then all the uh activities and
fun times that comes
afterwards yeah as much as we've seen
the brutal side of england we it's nice
to see
you know the joyous side of it as well
yeah and it's something we really wanted
to
to play on and in valhalla where
being a viking is not only about being a
raider or a warrior
i mean there's revelry there's feasting
there's partying that goes and like if
if someone knows how to party it's a
viking
and so here this is one of our
opportunities to sort of show that
show what a sort of viking gathering is
and what's cool here is it's a it's a
good alliance of
norse culture with saxon culture sort of
smashing those
two things together um and building
bridges
yeah i mean what's a wedding without
some drunk archery right
uh yeah so like anything can happen in a
in a viking event right cave or yeah
here here
you just get drunks and shoot some
arrows
ah barely a challenge steady all
and ready yourself for the wedding race
the king and his bride
against all my king he
so here we see the decision i made to
spare ruid
came back to bite us yup that that's the
decision you made
um coming back um so as we said before
all of your decisions have consequences
and this is a big one
i challenge you
i accept
you're basically presented with the
option to sort of step in for
oswald fight the fight for him or let
him
go and fight his own fight yeah you know
personally i chose to
fight myself because i thought avor is
the type of person who likes to finish
what she started
by plank and the dead king cannot keep
his oaths
let me finish this
us won't you cut this out your swine
i'll slay the wolf kissed then hang
so at this point you've eliminated his
wolf so it's just him and so he
he's angry at this point and so he will
start using his
his big gun abilities like fairly early
on in the fight
um so it's way more vicious way faster
there's less strategy he goes literally
swords blazing at you
um and so this is a fight to the death
and of course here like this is the
decision you made to go and fight him
but there's multiple outcomes to this
scenario you could have left
oswalt fight his own fight um and prove
basically
his station as as the rightful leader um
if you had eliminated
ruiz obviously this would not have
happened it would have been a slightly
more joyous occasion
um but ultimately in all scenarios you
still have an alliance
with oswald he's proven to be um the
right leader for this territory
um and to be a good ally for you a great
service
i promised you an alliance and now you
have it
and one day i will need you to make good
on that alliance
so we're about to take off from the
wedding but avor decides it's a good
idea to check up on her friend finner
yeah so finnette finner is probably one
of the more recurring characters in in
this arc you get to meet him very well
he's a very endearing character sort of
used to have a viking life sort of
misses it
and going through all these adventures
together
is sort of like uh lights that fire back
and so he's he's willing to join you and
your raiders um so he's one of many
raiders that you'll
you'll encounter in the game and you can
sort of recruit bring back home
and then have them sort of join you on
your adventures
on the long ship he can tell you these
stories that we're telling you about
to know a little bit more about him um
so again it's a fun way to
sort of discover more about these
characters that you meet and bring him
along for adventures
together together
i'll gather my things well folks we've
come to the end of our assassin's creed
valhalla play-through
fizz thank you so much for joining us
when and where can people play it
assassin's creed bahala will be out on
xbox series x and playstation 5
and is coming to xbox one playstation 4
pc and stadia on november 17th
hello everyone a happy sunday and
welcome to the gamespot post show
for ubisoft forward july edition because
apparently we're getting another one
uh it's some undetermined time i'm lucy
joined today by michael hyam
what up and tomorrow hussein
hello everyone now obviously we are
going to be discussing all the games
that ubisoft showed off in today's
ubisoft ford
event but it would be completely remiss
of us to not talk about the broader
context
and what is happening at ubisoft as a
company
right now uh we have a platform we're
going to use it they started off this
morning
uh i will read the tweet out ubisoft
forward comes during a time of big
internal change because all the content
has been pre-recorded
we wanted to recognize that the issues
we're currently dealing with won't be
addressed directly in the show we still
have significant work to do
and are committed to this process we
will provide more updates soon
i'm not going to go too deep into the
details but obviously there have been
allegations of uh sexual abuse
harassment
uh and other abuses people have stepped
down
they were well golden parachuting out of
the company
resigning from their positions um
personally speaking it is not that hard
to record a clip
and put it into a show i find this
excuse
quite frankly very disrespectful for all
the people the thousands of people who
still work at ubisoft it's all very well
and good
this is obviously a promotional show
they are promoting the games
but they need to have that commitment
that they are working towards
actually improving and what better way
than to use this
showcase to fully commit to that future
for
your thousands of employees and this the
survivors and the victims
i'm very disappointed
um personally speaking um
yeah yes it is i wanted to address that
time
yeah it's pretty unacceptable that a
company that large that is able to
you know create games on a global field
using utilizing multiple teams across
development marketing pr
is unable to put together even a short
statement from
someone in a position of authority to
address the biggest concern that people
have
around the games um you know they knew
that this event was going to happen well
in advance for
perhaps you know year a year plus now
and the allegations that have been
leveled at
ubisoft for its toxic work environment
the encouragement of
abuses of power the enablement of the
pieces of power as well
as the actual abuses of power themselves
whether they're physical sexual mental
whatever it may be
those have been coming out for quite a
few weeks now
um and the fact that they haven't been
able to pivot
to address this speaks to a
an unwillingness um to to kind of
support the people who have been
affected which they should be doing
and also to support the people who are
still at the studio it's
not that hard and people
and it should be thought of as
considerate and
smart and thoughtful to do that right
now especially as you're
showcasing the games that the thousands
of thousands
thousands of you know people at ubisoft
are
working on for the first time it would
have been
uh the ideal moment for leadership to
come out and say we are using your
talents your abilities your smarts your
experience to give the company a future
and in return this is what we're gonna
do
to make sure that all of that is
protected and you feel like we're
looking after you
and we're giving you a safe comfortable
working environment they didn't do that
and the excuse that we recorded in
advance
so we weren't able to pivot is frankly
unacceptable like it's
ridiculous
yeah i feel like if you can get i know i
know that it's
you know we're not going to hang on this
for too long because at the same time
these people have worked on these like
these thousands of people have worked on
these games and we want to talk about
them and celebrate those two but like
you had a pre-recorded phil spencer
presumably dialing in from his living
room yes the rest of the presentation
was slick it was done in a studio
presumably under
social distancing regulations was it
it's very very frustrating you know they
had a pre-show you could have addressed
it there
something more than just a tweet
michael yeah um well i guess what i'll
like y'all put it uh
pretty clearly and i think that all of
us here
stand by what tam and lucy said uh and i
also think that
my perception is that putting out that
tweet is
less than the bare minimum uh i think
there's a lot of people with
eyes on this event and of course we want
to celebrate those games but
leadership has at ubisoft has the
existing leadership
has come out and said that we are going
to make drastic changes
we're going to to try and promote a much
better more inclusive
uh safer work environment that would
have been the bare minimum to come out
in front and
like maybe eve gimmel would be up front
before his show any games
and say look we understand what's going
on here and then we are going we are
working extra hard
to just reiterate that message that
you've already said
it's already been stated that they are
quote-unquote trying to build a much
more inclusive and safer work
environment
do that at the front of the presentation
because there are a lot of people
watching
and maybe not everyone is privy to the
things that have been happening
within ubisoft's structure and the
pieces of power that have taken place
in there but i also think it's a
disservice to avoid it altogether when
everyone's watching
so i mean it's i don't think it's a good
look uh
and people who aren't privy to it uh may
still not know about what's going on and
i think it
like tams tam and lucy said it's a
disservice to a lot of the people who
are
like putting in a lot of hard work on
these games at ubisoft who
are there to work putting passion into
these things where
some leadership positions have been
abusing their positions so
i think you know moving forward i want
to see this confronted
uh in a much stronger way rather than
just platitudes
and i mean platitudes could have been
could have been the bare minimum for
this presentation we didn't even get
that but
i mean i think i'll for me i'll leave it
at that
yeah okay i'm gonna kind of move the
conversation along now i think we've all
definitely
said our piece and hoping to see some
meaningful change and statement from
ubisoft coming forward
um and like i said these games are made
by thousands of people we want to be
able to talk about their work
and not have it completely overshadowed
by the atrocities that have been
happening within ubisoft so
uh with that as a graceful segue as i'm
gonna get let's
talk about ubisoft forwards um
a little different for them in terms of
presentation they they have been kind of
i feel experimenting with this format a
little bit over time
uh they did you know obviously the
pre-show um and then you know
sort of this there are other titles the
ones that they're not really focusing on
right now
so you had uh trackmania uh little
things from hyperscape
and um updates for the division and
tom clancy then i mean the actual show
itself
kicked off with watch dogs and i'm very
i'm honestly quite conflicted about the
use of
um martin niemoller's uh first they came
speech uh
i honestly was not expecting and i
remember when i was interviewing
uh ubisoft uh developers last year for
watch dogs legion
they kind of said you know it's a
political game but please don't ask us
about brexit
um and it feels like they've really just
doubled down on this being a political
game and i think
calling in nee muller is and that and
all the connotations that that very
powerful poem holds is
you know quite the statement to make
michael i know you've had a lot of hands
on time with watch dogs again
legion and you've spoken to clint
hawking about it what are your
uh is that is that very much within the
game itself it's not just the marketing
uh i do i at least based on so i played
watchdogs legion for
four hours uh earlier this week to do
all my preview coverage you can check it
out gamespot.com but here
i'll try and contextualize it with what
was shown during the presentation
because
i do feel like there's a bit of a
disconnect with how
it's being presented or at least what
you saw in the presentation and what's
actually in the game
uh that's not to say like the game is
like this hardcore uh
revolutionary thing and it tries to
evoke some of that uh and i explore that
a little bit
and what i wrote uh but it was
like man they're they're messing they're
playing with
uh playing with fire which i think is in
on one
in one case i do think it's bold that
they are trying to evoke that
and have this game that tries to
contextualize
uprising and rebellion uh in a very very
real sense especially in 2020
this game is coming out this year and it
touches on a lot of different things
that we see out in the streets
this game is built around authoritarian
state taking over london
it's about police brutality and it's
about people
collective action and revolution and
you know if you're going to evoke a lot
of the language and imagery
of revolution in a very real way then
it's an expectation that you also do
right by it and i think the the the way
it was presented during the ubisoft
forward
uh like with with that with that video
was
a little tone-deaf uh especially also in
the context of what i played with
watchdogs legion so
um yeah it's
it's not great uh but as far as the game
itself
uh i do think that watchdog's legion is
i think it has a lot of potential to be
powerful to send a strong message
whether or not it follows through i mean
i only played four hours so
i didn't get that much of the story but
i do have concerns in certain areas
uh i don't know how deep how deep you
all want to go and go into it or if you
have any specific questions i can get
into
in some pretty deep detail if y'all want
yeah i mean i was gonna say so obviously
watch dogs one and two
you have the one core character who
you're controlling and following their
storyline through
this one you can kind of seemingly
recruit anyone within london
and the way that they were shown in this
presentation it was very much
kind of selecting the right person for
the job and honestly
when they were talking about the
different roles you know that had the
construction guy you had the guy who
actually worked for albion
i was getting big hitman vibes um
would you say that's right mike i said
exactly that in my preview
so i yeah i did a gameplay focus preview
and
that is the impression i got not in
terms of i mean
so you when you recruit a bunch of
people you can choose
uh who you want to play as at any moment
and everyone has their own
occupations which means they also have
their own outfits and costumes you can
outfit them in like normal clothes but
you can also switch to
what their specific occupation is and in
my preview
one mission took place in a construction
zone
and i had a construction worker so i
walked right in
where security guards is roaming around
and i'm there in my my hard hat and my
safety suit i'm just walking around like
nothing's going on
so i i infiltrated this this
construction site to
save a hostage or whatever and it gave
big hit man vibes because i'm just like
walking around avoiding detection not
trying to get too close
trying to take out guards where it's
necessary without being seen
and it has an element of silliness to it
i guess because of just like general
video game nonsense
uh and it was really fun i think
gameplay-wise it's it's pretty strong
uh and yeah like you're seeing in the
footage here uh the construction worker
can also call in
a carrier drone and you can get on top
of it while remotely controlling it to
fly up to
different places so there's a lot of
different tools at play that do remind
me of hitman
and yeah you can outfit yourself with a
spiderbot
and not a bunch of non-lethal weapons so
there's there's so many ways to approach
the missions now i don't expect the
missions to be designed
in such a deliberate detailed fashion as
a hitman game but i think
a lot of the a lot of them the the
gameplay beats that it's hitting
uh do remind me of my experience with
the hitman games
yeah one thing i wanna wanna yeah one
thing i wanna kind of like
talk about or just touch upon is the
kind of
uh the political angle again just a bit
i am you've written
a great piece that's on the site now
about it being definitely political but
one of the interesting things and
is something that you write in there is
ubisoft has a history of
evoking political context and
socio-political realities but then
you know also saying that it's not a
political game and their games do not
make any political statements
and i guess the thing that i want to say
is like we've kind of just sat by
and allowed it to happen in previous
years and been like well
you know it's been a thing that we've
talked about briefly and then we'll move
on but
i think the in watching the trailer for
this
um maybe it's because it hit home for me
as well i'm sure as
as it did for lucy and various other
people who around um the uk
um that i feel like i'm more
empowered now and i feel like it's more
necessary to place greater scrutiny
on what you know is being said in this
game so
i guess my my message is like ubisoft
has
previously kind of held his foot against
the door and not let anyone open the
discussion about
is this political um in a way that we
want to i don't think we can do that now
given the nature of the game um and how
how closely it um uh reflects real
current environments
it's it's our in our interest to you
know push through that door and break it
down and have that discussion
so that's one of the things i'm
interested in doing um and like hayam
discusses like uh moments from watch
dogs 2 where you know
the main character has this kind of
unique uh
discussion with another character and
it's all and watchdog 2 being one of the
games that is pretty cool in the
franchise and uh
they're giving it away for free to
anyone who watched it later so it's
worth playing just to see stuff like
that
um but like the reason that discussion
was important was because it's two black
characters that are speaking to each
other and they're able to relate to
their circumstances
so i guess my question for hayam is like
do you feel like there's opportunity to
do
that when the game is also about playing
anyone and everything
that's a that's a very good question and
i think it's going to rely
on so in the the con in
play as anyone you have to recruit
certain characters and there are
missions
tied to their recruitment process and i
think that's where it's going to have to
show
because there there are certain
characters to recruit that
uh are specific specifically baked in
and then so
i expect to get story tidbits out of
that so
one example is that uh
like i had to recruit an albion officer
and he has a friend
who needs medication and the healthcare
system is broken so he can't get it
there
the the gangs that run the street are
selling at a very high price so you
can't get it there so i need to help him
uh get those meds so there was like a
little bit a small piece of storytelling
that
spoke to a broken healthcare system now
as it relates to race
and how uh because obviously character
appearance is going to be randomly
generated i don't know how it's going to
handle that if
at all and that's definitely something
that everyone should be
have a key keen eye on is that how are
they going to
have those storytelling moments as it
relates to race because
systems of oppression and a police state
and police brutality
is inseparable from racial issues like
racism drives a lot of those elements
that this game is trying to touch on
so if it doesn't go all in on that in
some capacity
i do think it will fall short in that
regard and one thing i'll note is it's
kind of a small little line
uh in one of the main story missions so
nigel cass is the
r he runs albion which is the private
military corporation
that's overtaken london and he says a
small line
where quote unquote illegals are ruining
family families and that
like if you if you're gonna inject that
into
the narrative in some capacity you can't
just use that as set dressing
like if you have a character say that
then there's needs to be something that
pushes back on that message to make it
clear where this game stands
and the fact that the systems of
oppression also are
intertwined to race so uh
i don't know if it's i don't know if
it's going to come out of like the
characters themselves like it did in
watchdogs 2
but i i would hope that the characters
that surround this narrative
uh some of some of the more baked in
narrative pieces
they need they need to touch on that and
it needs to touch on the
the the inherent the fact that race and
capitalism are inherently tied to the
systems of oppression that watchdog's
legion is trying to portray
absolutely um before we move on from
watchdogs i just want to touch briefly
on
the setting of london itself uh ubisoft
also
obviously prides themselves on kind of
these recreations of worlds and
honestly feeling homesick for london
right now i don't know about you tim
yeah very much so yeah it looks really
good and i'm very
michael have you ever been to london i
haven't but i
i did in watch dogs legion but uh i also
i did a little bit a little
little research of like the locations
and stuff so i saw a big ben clock tower
uh went down the the thames river walk i
saw the london eye
i was in suther district i liberated
that district
oh really it's not southwark by the way
all the characters uh they gave me the
the lowdown on how to pronounce certain
things so i liberated southern for y'all
so you can head down there it's all good
the police presence is
uh is minimal at least it was in my demo
but
i think that if we're going to talk
about like the london location i think
it looks
looks great it's it's very much a
cyberpunk
sort of vibe because it's it's a tech
tech
dystopia at this point in the game uh so
it's visually pleasing but there's a lot
of imagery of
like you see a lot of electronic signs
saying albion police officers
obey the law or are you going to get
your ass beat and things like that or
like or you'll have messages hacked by
dedsec
and it'll say like power to the people
or things like that
uh some some of that imagery there but
overall like
i mean it same thing when watchdogs 2
went to the bay area
they were in the bay area and it was
really wild to drive around there and
like oh hey that's where the game spot
office is or hey i'm in oakland
uh you're gonna get that same vibe here
when you're playing watch dogs legion if
you've ever been to london and if you've
been homesick
and if you want to liberate your your
home city then by all means do that
uh so yeah but you know we'll see where
this where this narrative takes us
so i only played four hours and this is
a very big game but
it's important to keep a keep this your
keep your third eye open and be
skeptical and be critical of the things
even if you enjoy them
so i'll say that i imagine we'll see
more uh there's gonna be another ubisoft
forward we're not entirely sure when but
the game launches
october 29th uh at least one current gen
consoles they didn't really have a date
for next-gen
but they have confirmed that it will be
supported by xbox smart delivery so you
can get it on series x
and there's some strange verbage around
if you have it on
like i think they're also the growing
pains of going between
a generation where you can now get
obviously you can get a disc free xbox
but for playstation you know you can get
the disk
drive free playstation five so there's
some verbage that if you have
the ps4 disk as long as that disk is in
your ps5
you're gonna have to be careful i guess
if you buy it
on disc but then get the disc free ps
for ps4 but they get the discrete ps5
this is an interesting little wrinkle
that i didn't really see coming
but i guess we'll find out more uh when
the game launches later this year and
hopefully we'll get a date for next gen
i'm gonna rattle through some of the
other titles before we hit
on things like hyperscape and uh
assassin's creed so
brawlhalla coming to ios and android
august 16th
little hints for my magic tom clancy's
elite squad the elite
russell more like because they keep
showing um
another i just want to say for the
record ubisoft
if you are not gonna announce a splinter
cell game
stop putting sam fisher in things
like it is absurd and the only thing
that is gonna happen is you're gonna
rustle us we're going to get
upset and gamers will remember this
so your favorite noise
stop putting sam fisher in things if
you're not going to
put out a new splinter cell game either
tell us a splinter cell
or let that guy go ridiculous
let him be at rest
um all right and then moving on to hype
escape so
open beta on pc right now um 30 tier
battle pass
for free michael i know you're playing a
bunch um
are you excited are you going to dive in
again more yeah i'm definitely going to
give it another
another round or two or a couple more
rounds
i mean battle royales there's a lot of
them out there
and i got to play during the technical
tests and all that and
so i got to experience it a little bit
beforehand and
one thing i'll say is that it it does a
lot of different
and new things that other battle royales
have not
so i'll give it credit for that so it's
such as
feeling like an unreal tournament or a
quake it's very much
an arena shooter in many ways and the
way that it plays
from the combat especially because
you're jumping around you're double
jumping you're hopping from
rooftops and you're doing rocket jumps
and you're trying to line up splash
damage and you're trying to
line up shots against fast-moving
enemies that are also double jumping and
there's a bunch of abilities that you
pick up so there's no
it's not a hero shooter because there
are characters that you can choose to
have different voice lines that have
different aesthetics
but you also pick up powers throughout
the map so you're looting guns and
you're looting powers themselves
such as a cloaking ability or a super
high jump where you turn into a hamster
ball and
putting up a wall and things like that
so there's a lot of wild possibilities
in this game so
it's definitely trying some new things
and i think now that it's an open beta
and it's
also free to play i think it's it's
worth giving a shot
i think you know if you've been burned
down on battle royale though i don't
know if it's going to
like convince you otherwise but if you
are looking for something a little bit
fresher in the battle royale space i do
think hyperscape is worth giving a shot
uh maybe it'll it'll be for you i i
think that it has
some things to improve on uh but there
are exciting elements i
think my my favorite part is the end
game in which
the uh once you make it to the last few
squads instead of being the last squad
to survive
a crown will spawn into the map and if
you can
hold on to the crown for 45 seconds then
your team will win the match
regardless of how many players are
remaining it reminds me of oddball from
halo
so you need to hold on to it and but the
thing is like all the enemies will know
your location they will be pinged to
your location so you better
you better square up and get ready uh
for some wild fire fights
because uh yeah and shouts out to khalif
adams and blessing out of yoyo junior
they were my squad mates when we were
playing and we held it down for the
crown so
uh yeah we got that game play on game
spot if you want to peep that
thanks tam what about you because you
you and i play quite a lot of apex we're
playing a lot of warzone right now
um do i need to install it are we
pivoting
i mean maybe we'll see how it goes the
open beta is out there right now
um so i i'm definitely gonna have a
i think we should jump in and try it to
at least know where it stands amongst
the landscape of
um uh battle royale games and
multiplayer shooters
the way we play though we do stuff like
we'll start with one game and seemingly
move across every multiplayer game
in our you know kind of like sweet until
we we finished our play sessions so
we'll see if if if kind of like it can
slot in
around something else like i can imagine
us like maybe swapping out apex for a
bit
to play hype escape just because apex is
kind of like
we play like across uh you know internet
connections with people in the uk and
that kind of stuff as well
so and it's not the best at handling
that transatlantic
lag so i feel like there's an
opportunity for hyperescape to sneak in
and maybe like
uh push push apex out of the way if it's
got it going
um sadly it's not available on consoles
just yet
i don't believe the open beta is
available on the consoles just here
so i think it's apex still got has a
little bit of time in it to kind of
maybe grip us again
and put some extra content in there but
i'm definitely willing to give it a try
for you all
oh definitely i'm very interested in it
i know it's it's not necessarily
a hero shooter but there are a lot of it
that remind me of overwatch i think in
terms of abilities
um even though that's a 6v6 but i'm
intrigued
um i think i'll probably spend this week
doing that
um all right let's move on to assassin's
creed valhalla so we got
a little kind of 10-15 minute
presentation within ubisoft forward
itself and then after we got a post show
which was actually a pretty chunky bit
of gameplay a 30 minute gameplay demo uh
narrated
um i personally i was a little wary when
they started that presentation because
they were just showing the
the lovely blur pre-rendered cgi trailer
again
but um seeing it in action
i am genuinely like i'm a big assassin's
creed fan and i
am i love the fact that they've taken
the series in this direction
my big concern i think when i saw this
was yep i'm loving all of the changes
to uh more full-on gameplay full-on
combat you know
uh dual wielding different mix-and-match
weapons you can
um also there was a there was a moment
where um
you had a bow and arrow and you were
aiming at someone who was running
towards you
and he started zigzagging out of the way
which i play a lot of open world games
where you have a bow and arrow i don't
think i've ever seen that before that
was really cool
my one thing that i was concerned about
was obviously the origins the roots of
assassin's creed
the core tenets of that franchise are
stealth
and so i think certainly within
odyssey and origins you kind of lost
focus on the
on that um but i'm intrigued to see how
it's going to work for valhalla
i can't decide if i'm going to be my
usual stealth archer or if i'm actually
going to go in
um jewel wheels blazing
i guess michael what were your um what
were your what was your take on the
gameplay that we saw
um well first i want to give a shout out
to jordan remay who
previewed it for us one of our one of
our top lads
here at gamespot so he actually got
hands-on with it so
he'll have more details to share if you
want to read that but
from what i've seen and from what i've
read when i was helping edit
his feature is you know i'm
i'm ready for some open world nonsense
and i think that the
the combat is kind of it looks like it's
leaning more into
sort of uh the style that i'm i'm
looking for
but also it's this is just such a
it looks like a world that i want to
explore so i'm i'm down to get into some
nonsense to
kind of explore this uh you know this
european lush european world where you
know there's
vikings and stuff like that so uh but i
mean
i've also had my fair share of
assassin's creed games at this point i
did replay origins
recently so you know i
i'm not expecting something
revolutionary but there are a lot
it seems like there are a lot of dope
mechanics at play here and i think
jordan also mentioned
the different ways that you travel so
there's it's going to be easier to get
around different places
uh with fast traveling and some of the
narrative elements seem really
interesting as how it ties to
the the present day assassin's creed
sort of
narrative line i guess and the fact that
you can
switch a av or was it avor
uh between male and female at any time
and the fact that that has narrative
implications
that's i think i think now that i think
about it that's the thing that's going
to hook me like
i'm going to get into some open world
nonsense but i also want to get some
get something meaty out of it as well
like if you're going to take this this
this viking aesthetic this viking
setting uh i don't want it just
to just be about brutalizing my enemies
or anything like that i want
i want a little bit more chew on and i'm
getting a sense of that
yeah i think the way that they were
discussing it is you know when
they were obviously vikings well known
throughout history for
uh pillaging and raiding um but they
were trying to humanize them a little
bit by saying you know they left norway
there wasn't really much there they came
to england because
of all the abundant resources the lush
greenery
the castles and stuff
um and so trying to humanize that
process so i'm interested to see how
that works because
i guess throughout history we've always
learned that the vikings are just this
very harsh people but it also seems like
because you're building
your um your kind of home
it's not called a homestead your
settlement
and you know gathering resources and i'm
intrigued to see
how much that'll play into the gameplay
loop
tam uh what are your feelings on that
yeah i'm i'm really excited to have that
kind of
that's the one thing that i was kind of
missing in a lot of the recent
assassin's creed games like
investing in a place a little more like
they've done a great job of showing off
places but like
ac2 brotherhood that kind of feeling of
building up your own
um kind of like town what was it called
monterey journey or something like that
i can't remember what your own own
settlement thing was called here
um but like that and it makes perfect
sense for a game like this given the set
up with you know
we have these vikings trying to find a
new home uh
establishing that so i'm really excited
about that element of it
um and and seeing how it feeds i think
that that's what was exciting about the
ac2 element or like what's remembered
great about it is
there was so much of the main gameplay
that fed into that settlement building
in the original
ac2 series kind of stuff and so i'm
excited to see how
the the kind of like menial open world
gameplay
uh has an impact on that because that's
something that i've been really feeling
with open world games where you have all
these tasks and
and kind of like checklist stuff but it
doesn't really
result in anything major this is a great
way to go back to that classic
assassin's creed
two feeling of everything you do even if
it seems menial in the moment and
and not particularly satisfying you go
back to your settlement and you'll be
able to make it
um satisfying by investing in in a place
and
building it up and seeing your your
progression and growth which is
important in a game where
you know the rpg mechanics don't make it
super easy to feel that immediate growth
um you often have to spend hours and
hours and hours before you feel like all
right i'm getting somewhere my
character's powerful and i have these
weapons and armor
um but having a place and a people that
you can visibly see growing and
and making life better for them could be
an interesting way to
to kind of alleviate some of that uh
that kind of
grind um the other thing i'm really
excited about is the rocks
shout out to rocks stacking rocks i'm
going into rocks rocks
mvp 2020 and the rock says let's do this
i genuinely thought you're going to say
you were very excited about recruiting
cats but they're right oh yeah the cat
thing is
the cat thing is like a side side thing
that i'm going to be writing at least
five thousand words on
and maybe doing like three or four
videos damn just put cats in your game
and you're gonna get you're gonna get
free coverage from tam man
easy easy you um
before we move on from assassin's creed
a couple more things i wanted to pick up
on
um i like the uh kind of gathering your
army and storming fortresses which is a
very different kind of take
um i guess in assassin's creed where you
typically go in
you are the one man or woman army and
you sort of try and stealth kill
everyone but this one i was getting kind
of shadow of war vibes
you know gathering an army and reigning
destruction down on the stronghold which
i'm very excited about
um and also big fan of the fact that on
your ship
you will have crewmates who not only
will sing songs but they will have
little stories that they're gonna tell
again those nice little humanizing
aspects of assassin's creed games which
i'm a very big
fan of games coming out november 17th um
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x pc
and stadia
which i completed there are in fact
people playing stadia
it would seem uh i'm interested to see
how it's gonna run honestly
um i feel like stadium's been quite
quiet recently
um all right and then they ended the
show with
i always feel really bad when a game
leaks um especially one as high profile
as far cry
6. um you know we got that image the i
think the storefront
uh for far cry 6 leaked and it's got
giancarlo esposito
best known as gus ring from breaking bad
um
i'm honestly like i know that they
showed off the the lovely i assume blur
studios fancy um cgi trailer
but there are more details about this
game that are kind of coming out um
alessandro
valeri on our site i got a pre-brief on
it has written some stuff up if you want
to read more but it sounds really
like honestly interesting and i fully
buy into the theory that this kid
is vas it's got the same scar over his
right eyebrow
i'm into it i've got my tinfoil hair
ready um but the lowdown
they kind of like they didn't really go
into too much detail in this trailer
is obviously uh giancarlo is the
president
he's a dictators named anton castillo of
the island of yara which is kind of
a place held back in time by his
dictatorship
um he has his son here diego and
uh you don't play as diego which i
thought that that was what was going to
be
leading up to you actually plays a
character called danny rojas uh you can
play as a male or a female um and you're
working to overthrow the dictatorship
um and it has you know things that they
introduced in far cry
4 or 5 um you know the fangs for hire
and the one that i picked up on is the
fact that there is a little wiener dog
called chorizo
which i'm very excited about uh michael
you were talking earlier about some
open world madness um far cry is pretty
much
the franchise for that are you excited
to head to the island of yara
uh before i get excited about any open
world nonsense when it comes to far cry
6
i think that uh there are a lot of
things that need to be addressed about
it and it's setting because it is
again it's it's kind of like watchdog's
legion this is almost a a theme for
ubisoft at this point is like they are
saying we're not we are now
embracing the political messages behind
these games
and that very much comes through in the
imagery that is in this trailer and also
comes through in alessandro's interview
that you can catch on gamespot so like i
said with watchdogs legion is that if
you are
going to evoke these messages then you
got to do right and buy them
and i don't like listen video games in
general have
had general i actually i would say
almost across the board poor
representation of latinx people
uh you know it's oftentimes they
are relegated to being
uh like these like unhinged or gang
members like in watch dogs too
uh or just playing into stereotypes
right
but here it's it's about the people of
yara
taking the revolution in its own country
so it's not gonna have this
this [ __ ] ass white savior complex
at least
and i hope it follows through on that um
but
you know these it's hard to do these
things right in a video game setting
especially when the main verb is to
shoot and kill i would assume since this
is a far cry game
uh so it's it's it's very touchy and
especially
when you are trying this is basically
cuba that's my impression i'm getting
that yara is a parallel to cuba
so it's going to evoke a lot of themes
of again authoritarianism
and revolution and uprising and what it
takes
what these things actually mean what are
the systems of oppression and how do
they affect the people and how do the
people react to it
uh so they're they're gonna be messing
with some pretty heavy themes and
far cry doesn't have a great track
record when it comes to those things
but you know i think this pivot
towards embracing the political side of
things and having
the devs up front about the fact that
they are trying to go for this
revolutionary message it does give me
some semblance of hope but i don't think
you can blame anyone who
is skeptical about whether or not it's
going to land right
so i'll leave it at that uh when it
comes to that but i
personally i like as a brown person
and as what they would say a latino of
asia
uh so i would hope that
you know that this is this is gonna give
fair representation
uh when it comes to latinx people
absolutely uh tam i wanted to ask you so
ubisoft putting out three very meaty
open world games
in very quick succession you know you've
got watchdogs in
october followed by assassins in
november and then
far cry is coming out in february that's
a lot of games
for not a long amount of time which one
do you think you're going to prioritize
and do you think this is maybe a mistake
for them to put three of them
so close together i don't know if it's a
mistake i think they
for for our audience it might feel like
there's going to be inevitable fatigue
around it
i think that they've had this in the
past where you know there were
complaints about all of ubisoft's game
starting to bleed together and have this
like open world checklist map feature
style thing
and i think to some extent that is still
somewhat present but i think each of the
games are now doing something distinct
enough that
they have you know the ability to stand
out
more more like broadly speaking to the
you know
people outside of the hardcore um
audience that we speak to um there's
probably
gonna be situations where someone picks
and you know and it's like i'm gonna i'm
a far cry person i like far cry
because i like shooters and i'm gonna
get into that whereas you know there are
you know countless assassins creed fans
who know that once they get that
assassin's creed that's them for like
six months or maybe
um and then watchdogs is still
for for as much as we think about it
watchdogs is still a franchise in its
infancy and i feel like the awareness
around it
feels more than it is because of our
position in the industry like
i don't know that many people or i'll
say that i don't
think people speak of watchdogs on the
same playing field
as you know assassin's creed and even
far cry
those are games with a long lineage
whereas um
watchdogs is kind of the new kid on the
block so i feel like people might
just kind of like pick it up as a curio
or something like oh this looks
interesting
i think there's the smartest thing
they've done is is make the game in
london because that's a huge kind of
unique
uh selling point for it as well now um
i feel like there will be fatigue but i
don't necessarily think it's a mistake
um for myself personally i think it's
the same as with
you guys i imagine like i will be
playing all of them i don't think i will
i'm i'm inclined to like play all of
them in succession
like i might space one of them out and
put it later
and if i had to do that it would
probably be far cry
which thankfully is coming out a few
months after anyway
but i'm excited for each one and i think
they all have something unique
to offer um to to kind of
compel me to play all of them even if
they are quite similar in a lot of
regards
all right we're just about gonna wrap up
here uh michael what are your final
thoughts on
the very first ubisoft forward
uh they got they got some some
interesting games lined up i think
gameplay-wise
it's it's pretty much a i wouldn't say a
guarantee but i would
bet on them being fun to play uh ubisoft
is very good at building
fascinating open worlds with a ton of
stuff to do
i think like watchdogs legion i'm so the
thing about watchdog's legion is like
i'm more excited
now for it than i was before even though
i'm even more skeptical about how it's
going to handle its themes
because it's gameplay i think is
fascinating and i do
like that they are embracing uh its
themes
so i think that now like at least now
that we know what these games are with
far cry 6 watchdogs legion
assassins creed uh to a lesser extent
but now that we know
that they are going all in on these
themes
now is the time for these games to show
us that they mean it
uh and you know i'm not gonna discount
these games before they're out
but i am going to be keeping a sharp eye
when i play these games about
how it's doing its storytelling uh what
how it pieces its narrative together
uh so with that i will say that i am
looking forward to these games and i'm
looking forward to dissecting what they
have to say and also
the open world hygiene that comes with
it
tim what about you yeah i think i call a
lot of what
i am said there i think watchdogs looks
interesting assassin's creed looks great
um watch out was great as well and i'm
excited to get back into
um a far cry game especially with this
vast conspiracy surrounding it
um but i i
think hayam's right like we we need to
pay more
put those games under more scrutiny
narratively speaking
um they are inviting us to do so and we
should absolutely do that
i think each of those games um has like
i said previously a distinct
gameplay loop now hopefully but the most
interesting aspects of them are the
narrative and the characterization and
the rocks and cats in assassin's creed
valhalla
i'll always also say is that um the oops
for a first you know attempt at ubisoft
forward um
i think it went down pretty well
obviously there's the one thing that we
wish they could have handled better and
we will continue to hold them
accountable for that stuff um
but as far as nintendo direct clones go
it's pretty good um and if they're gonna
do it again
do not mention sam fisher unless you're
mentioning the game
i just to reiterate stop that [ __ ]
behave yourself either give us a split
or just let it go relax
leave sam fisher alone we already lost
we already lost snake we cannot lose
another
stealth icon and we won't sit by and let
it happen in this way
let him go let him hang out with snake
just leave the sneaky boys alone
i agree with basically what the two of
you um
said so i'm kind of not going to
reiterate those points but leave the
sneaky boys alone
um there will be another episode forward
in the future
um i hope that we're gonna see more of
you know gods and monsters
um beyond good and evil too it's a
little curio that's just kind of
skull and bones
god uh i don't even remember the last
time we heard anything from skull
bones um i think i interviewed them like
you know three
four years ago at this point about that
game fingers crossed they're doing all
right
um and yeah we will obviously be
covering
uh those ubisoft forwards as they happen
just like we will be
covering the xbox series x uh inside
xbox
on july 23rd as well as all the other
huge game announcements hands-on etc etc
from across the summer so make sure to
stay tuned to gamestop.com youtube.com
gamespot on behalf of myself michael and
tam thank you so
much for watching i'll see you next time
peace play bloodborne i couldn't even
say much there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you